This is Jocko podcast number one 37 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo and good evening.
If you know the way broadly,
you will see it in all things
and that is a simplified quote from Musashi's book of five rings and it's a
solid quote.
Make sense?
I'd,
I believe it to be true,
but at the same time,
while I agree with Musashi that if you know the way broadly,
you'll see it in all things.
There's a little bit of a problem with that concept and the problem is how do
you get to know the way broadly?
I mean the way is no easy thing to grasp.
You weren't born with it.
You don't just wake up with it.
It's something that you have to learn and it's something that you are always
still learning,
but even though you have to learn the way at the same time,
learning the way is hard because of the way is something that's hard to teach.
Then recently I've been asked a couple by a couple different people in a couple
of different scenarios how I learned what I learned,
how have I learned what I learned and this is believe me,
no claim that I know what ton of stuff I don't,
as I just said,
I am still learning.
But I will say that I do know the way broadly enough that I now see it
everywhere and in everything.
So
how did I learn the way?
Well it's kind of interesting cause it's a combination of actually it's more of
a collision of a bunch of different things.
Of course my time in the seal teams and I do trace a lot of it back to the seal
platoon where we had a little mutiny.
We hired a bad boss and we ended up turning against him and he got fired and
replaced by the best boss and,
and the juxtaposition and the contrast between really good leadership and really
badly or ship made it very clear.
Okay.
But it wasn't just that I,
of course,
I had other great guys that I work with in the seal teams that taught me a ton
of great instructor cadre that put me through training,
taught me a ton and you want,
I realized I always paid close attention to leadership and tactics and I think
that's probably because I sought something that I might be able to get good at.
Since there was a lot of things that I wasn't naturally good,
I wasn't naturally the strongest,
I wasn't naturally the fastest,
I wasn't naturally the best shot.
So I kind of paid attention to leadership and I paid attention to who did it
well and who didn't.
And I paid attention to tactics and I paid attention to what worked and what
didn't.
From a tactical perspective,
and I read now,
I will tell you right now,
I did not read a lot by any stretch,
especially compared to how much I read right now.
But I read some important books that had a big impact on me.
And of course they were only books about war and in those books about war,
the things that I actually paid attention to,
it wasn't like the,
wasn't the,
the the political situation that was going on.
I,
I paid attention to the leadership.
I paid attention to the tactics.
I paid attention to the human nature of how men reacted to war.
And so some of those books,
and again,
it wasn't a lot about face with the old breed battle leadership,
the last hundred yards,
some very straightforward books and books that I'd covered early on this
podcast.
And then of course on top of that I got lucky with my deployments overseas and I
got to experience war from a leadership perspective
and I started to see how things overlapped and intertwined.
And one of the things that really helped me see the connections between
leadership and tactics and human nature and life in general was Jujitsu.
I talk about digital a lot.
Obviously we talk about Jujitsu a lot.
Jujitsu is a simple,
straight forward,
practical representation of the way.
If you think about what you did too,
hasn't it?
Right?
It has.
Oftentimes it has defense.
It has flanking,
they'd has conservation of energy.
It has deception.
It has attack.
It has concentration of effort.
It has position improving your position.
It has maneuvering.
It has placing Bates and using faints and always keeping your base and keeping
your balance while at the same time trying to upset your opponents.
Now,
everything I just said,
you could use that for combat,
for tactical situations.
You could also use it in business.
You could use it in interactions with other human beings as you maneuver through
human nature and how it you interact with it and their psychological elements
inside of Jujitsu as well that are reflected humility.
You're gonna get humbled by Jujitsu and at the same time dichotomy,
you're going to gain confidence.
You're going to know the truth.
You're going to know where you actually stand.
You know it's not you're going to get a belt,
but that belt,
it only represents
it only.
It doesn't fully represent the reality of the situation.
The reality of the situation is the truth.
And in Jujitsu,
you know the truth.
You're going to be vulnerable.
You're going to,
you're psychologically,
you're going to learn about tenacity.
You're going to,
you're going to have to have grit,
you're going to have to have durability,
you're going to have to have stability.
And as I trained Jujitsu and I had garnered a better understanding of Jujitsu,
I just started to have a better understanding of the way.
And as I learned the way on the maths,
the way revealed itself in combat,
it revealed itself in leadership,
in human nature and in life.
Because as you and I talk about this as well as you understand things from
different angles,
right?
So when you learned the way in different disciplines and you start to see it
from different angles,
and eventually
I came to understand the way broadly
and now I do see it in everything.
And this is another thing.
The more I see it in everything,
the more I see it in everything.
So understanding the way,
like I said,
a lot of it had to do with this thread.
And I talked about it when we,
when we talked about judo,
I talked about how Jujitsu is the thing that started.
I started to see a connective thread between these,
between these different disciplines
and
a lot of it.
My understanding of Jujitsu helped me in every other aspect and a lot of my,
in fact the vast majority of my understanding of Jujitsu comes from one person
and the person I was lucky enough to learn from the,
as a pioneer of the sport
considered by many people to be one of the greatest rappers ever
a PR.
He's a practitioner that actually revolutionized the sport of Jiu Jitsu and
grappling and his influence is still evident today.
World champion multiple times over.
Also a mixed martial arts fighter who has faced some of the best in the world
and some of the biggest arenas in that sport
and someone who I've trained on the mats of Justice with for over 20 years and
who's been a close friend of mine.
That whole through
many ups and downs through victories and defeats through struggles of life on
and off the mat,
master of Jujitsu and
more important a friend of mine,
my brother Dean lister who is now finally coming on the show.
Dean,
welcome to the show shut.
Gow
great to be a brother.
Thank you for the invite.
Yeah,
man.
Uh,
let's start at the beginning and I was thinking about,
I know a little bit about your beginning and,
but I actually didn't realize that,
I know that you were raised somewhat in Panama,
but where were you actually born?
Born in Camp Pendleton.
Osha side here in San Diego.
Was Your Dad was in the marines,
right?
That's right.
So I'm a native of San Diego,
but um,
two years ago,
up in Venezuela,
uh,
two years in Panama and uh,
my whole life had been on all around the world and traveling,
learning in the world and it was very important to study.
How old were you?
How old were you when you moved to Venezuela?
I was in third grade,
so eight,
nine years to go right into Spanish speaking school.
They had English and Spanish at the time.
I didn't speak Spanish.
That was actually a problem for me.
And I actually learned Spanish fluently when I lived in Panama was a junior high
and that was of course you go to a Spanish school,
Spanish speaking school or did you just learn it out in the streets?
I learned best from let's say free rolling.
Say talking,
saying something,
you do it wrong.
You actually learn how to speak better.
Uh,
so I've actually been dropped off in countries and learn languages that way.
It's the best way actually.
So you have no choice.
Immersion.
Exactly.
Um,
in Panama it was a dod depart of different school and that matter of fact,
they used my junior highs.
There's a hospital field hospital and during the Panama invasion and uh,
that,
that's where I actually learned Spanish.
Uh,
I had survival Spanish when I was a little kid,
but Panama.
What years did you live in Panama?
89 88.
So I was a seventh and eighth grade.
Around that time,
seventh and eighth grade.
You lived in Panama?
The invasion went down in 89 with this,
I think December of September 18th or 20th,
forget.
Yeah,
and you are like in it,
it was a,
it was happening around you.
What happened was,
uh,
Fort Amador,
which actually means Fort Lover in Spanish.
It's a navy base.
It's not a very big base,
but it's the only base in Panama that was,
were trying to make a joint effort to have half Panamanian.
Well,
imagine I was in the middle of about maybe 80 yards from where my house was down
a hill about 40 guys got massacred there,
a front gate to the base.
Um,
some pdf,
the pediment to French forces,
police,
military,
same thing down there.
They,
they did try to run a marine roadblock in a bus that's not going to work out
good for them.
And uh,
the marine side,
50 cal,
just
the bus grinded to a halt of basically
didn't make it.
And so,
yeah.
What did they do with the families during that time?
What's the like what did your,
I mean,
your dad died after worker.
He was,
he was at quarry heights,
which was the main headquarters.
So he was,
uh,
basically underground this big rock,
and he could not tell us.
So he knew,
but there's no way it was like top secret,
whatever,
compartmentalize,
whatever you would say as far as he couldn't let us know and they didn't,
he didn't,
didn't send you out of the country.
It happened real fast because they killed a marine lieutenant,
I believe her name was lieutenant pause.
And uh,
that was,
uh,
maybe,
yeah,
that was not the reason.
That was the straw that not the straw,
that boulder that broke the camel's back for sure.
And,
uh,
sending,
all our forces.
And that caused me some problems though,
Eh,
and school because,
uh,
most of the kids were Panamanian kids that were,
they called them [inaudible].
Their parents worked on the Panama Canal.
And so they were pretty well off.
I went,
did,
he's in a school down there.
And because of that,
everyone,
everyone from Panama had an uncle or a cousin who died.
And so they see me,
by the way,
I was a goofy little kid.
I'm not saying I wasn't tough,
it was just goofy,
so didn't speak Spanish.
Uh,
I was goofy.
my social skills were a little bit awkward.
Maybe they are to this day actually.
And uh,
that's a recipe for disaster.
Right.
So scrawny,
I was always,
I was always tough,
scrawny,
but I wasn't,
I didn't get big until I was like 16,
17 and started growing real fast.
Yeah.
And so you were getting scraps down their basic rights cause you were in a
gringo.
Oh,
can go.
We call this Yankee down there.
Gringo didn't exist.
That's everyone was Yankee go home.
It was everywhere.
And it just felt wrong.
Hoem
and Yankee was y a n Q.
U.
I smelled like Spanish.
So the school was on base.
No,
no,
you take a bus.
Matter of fact,
it was really stupid.
Um,
the Iti had a failed coup about,
I think two weeks before the invasion.
One of a Noriega,
Manuel Noriega's,
a top guys generals successfully took them down.
And uh,
the loyalist tube to Noriega came to his rescue and the general surrendered.
But that day the country was on high alert.
And we're going home on the bus back to get dropped off it,
but to my base and other bases and uh,
the penny,
meaning a pdf,
penny meaning defense force skies when a machine gun nest just,
and I'm telling you all these high school kids,
I knew enough to just shut up.
They opened the window and started talking and these guys and these guys had,
what are the [inaudible] w was pointed right at us and they were like looking at
us and I'm man,
they didn't shoot us.
But that was one of the things when you're young,
you do stupid things.
So yeah.
So I was right there.
It was,
um,
that was a crazy time.
It was good though.
I'm actually glad.
Uh,
and this is,
oh,
I was teased Jocko,
which is,
I don't think he appreciates it,
but I was like,
chocolate.
I saw war before you.
It's true.
Junk was like,
yeah,
whatever.
So I've seen one 10th of 1% or whatever of 10 years old.
I was 1313.
It's actually,
you actually had more of an understanding if you were a little bit younger.
Yeah.
You might not really get it,
but you got enough understanding to realize that you are in danger and stuff.
Yeah.
So for 24 hours we were all alone,
pitch dark.
Uh,
basically I was just on the ground for three days and,
uh,
my mom filled the bathtub with water and I thought it was gonna die.
It really,
you know,
you're 12 years old,
didn't make a lot,
but uh,
that changed my life.
I should just stop just to have that experience.
It's actually a good thing on base that was secured by,
it wasn't US forces,
it was becoming security.
It was the only base in Panama that was half Panamanian across the street,
down a hill was the Panamanian officers.
So it was a joint effort and my situation,
most of the,
uh,
us kids or like for Howard,
they were an Rodman.
There were over this hills,
they heard gunshots and uh,
you know,
concussions,
whatever.
But they didn't see anything.
Right.
That might've seen you a few tracers.
But yeah,
it was right in the middle day rounds.
Hit Your House.
Uh,
w we are top of the hill.
So a few things,
uh,
chip the top of our roof and for sure if you want by windows someone could shoot
you.
So we didn't do that of course.
And we just drink out of a bathtub.
It was just you and your you and you're my sister,
sister.
My Mom and dad was at work.
My Dad was,
he was working,
he must have freaked out our neighbor,
we had giant yards between these houses.
Nice houses actually.
And the neighbor,
she was all by herself,
so it was just no cage.
She ran over,
uh,
across us,
I'd say a hundred yards.
The yards were really wide and she's knocking our doors.
She came inside.
She,
we had a fourth.
It was young,
young lady to me.
It was an old lady for about 25 to me.
That was an older person you have ever seen in her life.
She came in,
she had leave any weapons at the house.
Damn.
I've been like daddy for a reason.
I would have strapped up and go get,
not really,
but yeah,
my dad was a,
yeah,
it was just a sudden thing.
It was short notice.
And he was,
yeah,
but happening around,
I don't know,
11 before midnight,
1135 or something.
I thought it was firecrackers first and just shaking and flashes everywhere.
Just chaotic chaos.
And then did you finish out that school year?
So that goes down in December.
It was Scott [inaudible] pretty quickly.
Yeah,
let's say three days of two days of very intense.
First Day was the most,
second was serious,
third was okay.
And the next week was just mop up operations.
So it's still for 10 days it was,
it was dangerous.
But the first,
um,
one of my teachers from my junior high got got killed and a wizard just out in
the street.
They're long time and he was living in town actually.
That's why he's in the wrong place.
Wrong time.
I don't know how I got shot,
but I'm not,
I'm not sure by who,
but the wrong place.
Wrong time.
So,
uh,
yeah,
right in the middle of it.
Yeah.
We used to go down to Panama to do jungle training and is awesome.
But it was after.
I mean this is in the nineties so,
but I,
we went in and we'd look around and try and find,
you know,
where some of these battles took place in.
And it was interesting.
So then when you,
you see,
did you finish out that school year?
Halfway through we moved to San Diego.
Okay.
To high school down here.
And then you went down.
Now if you were down there,
did you start,
did you start getting interested in martial arts when you getting picked on?
I was doing karate.
Karate now I did wrestling for one year when I was eight years old.
My Dad made me do it and I didn't like it at the time,
but I'm really glad he made me do it cause that helped me a lot in flights.
It's a weird,
it's a weird thing with kids.
Like you know that it's good that he made you do it.
But if he,
he might,
he,
if he made you do it even more,
I might be,
you would just say,
Hey,
I'm not getting the wrestling high school.
I wanted to wrestle.
And so that's good.
So then we got to San Diego and now,
and you also played football.
Yes.
Where you better at football?
Are you better at wrestling?
Wrestling?
I was a good tackler.
I was one of the top one or two best tacklers not the fastest guy,
an average.
But really my body is not made for sprinting.
It's made for grabbing people.
Did you start,
did you,
you are a mutant.
Um,
did you start,
did you,
was that,
so you,
what grade was it that you wrestled in for one year?
Is that like sixth grade or something?
Oh,
you said you were 39 years old maybe.
So now your freshman year in high school was the first year that you actually
started wrestling freshmen.
I skipped 10th grade because I wanted to focus on weights and football mistake,
but it's okay.
And then 11th and 12th grade I wrestled and I was varsity 11 to 12 and I was,
the regional did that well with out that much experience.
I don't know why,
but for me,
well I do know why because you're,
you know,
you just joked about being like a mute and grappler,
but you actually literally have
like you were designed to grapple,
serious ran.
Uh,
so yeah.
So that's proof right there.
Is that you,
is that you,
you wrestled once when you were eight years old and then you wrestled and
freshman year and then,
I mean there's kids,
there's kids that wrestled their whole lives in there that you're wrestling
against.
Yes.
And how did you do?
Uh,
I would say South Bay regional champion.
I took third and county.
Um,
I wasn't that good until 1920 for some reason.
This submission arts sambal and a Jujitsu guys who will beat me in high school.
What you said,
1920,
19 2019 or 20.
Oh,
okay.
Got around the time I got out for that.
It can coordinate it.
I was kind of clumsy when I was 17.
So those kids that beat me,
one guy beat me,
almost tech falls me,
which means almost got 15 to two army or whatever.
He was from our local high school.
And I faced him in a after
high school and I pinned him in 30 seconds.
So I dunno why,
just a late bloomer and also you have this natural gift that you'd hadn't
started to hone yet and once you started to hone age just started to make sense.
It was the submission that got me really interested and just,
okay,
so from eight since Samba,
right psalm was your introduction to subway did Jujitsu?
Yes.
Sambos for those would don't know.
It's,
it's a Russian grappling style.
I would roughly compare it maybe in the middle of judo and Entergy sued because
they the stress a little more wrestling then judo and a little more submissions.
It's in the middle that say,
yeah.
So I would say it's sort of like in the middle of wrestling,
judo and Jujitsu.
Like you got to put all three of them together.
It's like a collage because you wear a jacket,
jacket,
shorts,
you wear shorts and shoes.
Yeah.
Which is,
which is literally,
he combination of everything go for foot.
Locks was in judo.
You can't go from foot logs.
Uh,
you can go for a single leg,
double leg.
We're in judo.
You can't do that.
So,
um,
yeah.
Where'd you hear about Samba?
My was my off season coach named Jerry Matsumoto down at my high school,
hilltop high school,
and Chew lavise.here in San Diego and an off season.
He was teaching this thing called Sambo.
This is right,
right before UFC one.
So,
um,
and what's that stuff with the jacket and what's this?
And they said,
oh,
this is submission.
What is a submission?
I was like,
17,
oh,
you can get your arm broken.
I'm like,
and I told myself,
and this is something that this one,
the not few,
several things Jocko and myself share,
we haven't common.
I told myself at age 17,
even though I was uncoordinated,
I said,
that's scary.
And I now I have to do it.
I gotta do it now.
If I don't do it now,
I'm uh,
I'm,
uh,
I'll feel ashamed of myself.
So I did it for some reason that guys that could beat me in Greco or freestyle,
I could submit them.
I don't know why.
I have no idea why,
but it was making sense for me.
And uh,
then I went to Jiu Jitsu at fabulous sound,
those
and,
and you know,
you say like you were naturally good at Zombot and you were,
and you,
you were like the national champion two time national champion in Samba,
right?
Yeah,
it's amateur.
At that time it wasn't really super popular,
but that prepared me in the American rules of Sambal because the athletic
commissioner,
the union was a no twisting submissions,
no chokes.
So street full lock straight and you lock in the street on lock so you can get
good.
Those three submissions,
three submissions then yes,
because those were the days where they thought,
oh,
like Steven Seagal grabbed your neck and breaks it,
you'll die.
Oh,
you get choked.
You Die.
Yeah.
Like,
oh by the way,
that ruins war movies.
When I see the guy sneak up behind you down with a machine gun that chokes him
and the guy's like done for the movie.
I'm like,
he's going to wake up in 10 seconds and then shoot you.
So kind of add to kind of separate myself.
At the moment,
but,
but yeah,
at that time,
right at the time,
USC one to peel thought it's important for people to know that there's a key
element here in Samba
is that the foot lock,
the straight full locking,
the knee,
the straight knee lock was one with the two of the three submissions you were
allowed to do and you were good at them.
When I studied Higgs would tell you this.
Oh,
and our good friends,
Jeff Higgs,
uh,
I came in there and actually was submitting guys and uh,
but they didn't like that because yeah,
I was,
I was the sambal kid.
Oh,
that's right kid for awhile,
for awhile I used to get people in bear hugs from the guard and make them top.
I was like,
I was a mean little bastard.
I made a,
well,
I don't think he's listening,
but if he has forgiven me,
but his name was John,
he was,
this isn't coach for Fabio and he was blue belt for striped.
I came in,
I caught him in full guard,
bear hug.
He's got you.
He tapped,
he screamed and then he went,
he was crying.
But my back from the garden,
that's all I knew so well and lived the past again,
you have some,
you have some mutated um,
structure that is maybe more for grappling than anything.
It's very odd.
And,
and,
and I remember you told me you would like arm lock people in their,
there you be in their garden and you arm lock them.
They'd reach for under oath.
I locked my postulate that the time that they said,
I didn't know you could arm lock someone from the garden.
I'm like,
well they aren't there.
They're like,
well,
I was taught that's wrong.
And uh,
well eventually I learned that that's not the best way to do it.
Yeah.
And so then it was at UFC one where you said,
oh,
do Jitsu,
what's going on with that?
Yeah,
because that was the time when choke holds.
We're like,
what do you feel like you're going to die?
Will you realize?
Not really the guy,
you know,
second USC,
no one died 30 go see you in choke holds actually work.
And nowadays people will can sometimes say,
oh,
Jitsu is,
it's not the most,
it's really,
it's a base.
It's a prerequisite.
You have to have the would be competitive.
So yeah,
very effective,
very effective.
And of course the sport has evolved technically over the years.
If you look at technology and technique are kind of similar because they develop
over time.
The technique of boxing now is different in the 80s and that's different from
the 50s football looks different now than back then.
Jitsu is the same thing,
right?
All kinds of things happening right now that no one even envisioned back in 1995
and it compounds faster,
right?
Like if you watch how fast technology's gotten has improved.
If you watched the Jujitsu curve,
it's like the new moves,
you know,
back when we,
when we started,
there'd be like a new move.
It wouldn't be locked up.
Oh my God,
this is crazy that this could,
someone came up with something and now there's,
you know,
some blue belt tonight came up with like a sick of variation of a move and,
and that's just the way it works.
So it's like everyone's better.
I,
I started eight months,
I don't know,
maybe one year,
maybe six months before you.
And so you for sure had already joined this time,
but the Omoplata was a brand new move and if someone did that at a tournament I
was like,
Oh look,
he's doing a brand new move and then we'll look at,
take the VHS camcorders and look at it.
And was like,
oh that was a highlight.
That was like the band Bolo or you know,
now it's leg locks up course.
So what was it?
So was it the UFC when you ask you a few like all right,
I got to find a Jujitsu gym and you open up the yellow pages or whatever.
No one knows about like yellow pages.
No,
Fabio had an ad in the San Diego Sr.
Yeah,
he was like this.
That's where I,
that's what I remembered that Fabio Santos had in the San Diego reader.
I remember seeing that.
But it was Higgs that brought me down cause Higgs had been trained in there for
awhile.
So you,
you,
I mean you were good fast,
right?
Sometimes I'll think,
man,
I'm really faltering here.
Nothing's happening,
and then next month I realize I'm twice as good as I was and I'll go,
what happened?
And then I feel like I'm losing ground.
I think that's because you're learning.
Sometimes you,
you learn a little bit,
but because it's something new you might be in better actually go down and
performance.
Yeah,
because you're,
you don't have that down yet and then of course you get it down to that higher
level of technique.
Now you're up to here.
I explained that to business,
like businesses want to implement a new process and I'm like,
you have to tell the people that out of the gate you're going to get less
efficient.
You implement a new process,
you're going to get less efficient than once you master the new process,
you'll get more efficient.
It's the same thing.
Would you do get to,
you started implementing a new move,
you're going to get worse and then once you master the move where you get good
at to move,
then you'll start getting better again.
Did we go real fast?
I'm going to,
I'm going to lend to you an analogy for that.
This very simple I heard nowadays,
Kurt kids don't even learn cursive.
Now I heard that,
I don't know,
but he learned printing and a few years you're writing your name,
it put glitter on it.
You give it to your mom.
She puts in the fridge on a little kid riding,
but I don't have to.
For years,
you're writing your name and you could write and say,
we're going to learn cursive now.
Well,
your cursive looks way more jacked up than your printing,
but it's a more advanced form of writing.
So we get that down.
And then back then,
by the way,
there's no typing in high school.
That was June.
It was college.
So in college you learned typing.
Initially you're just like,
hm,
you're slower than you would.
Right?
But eventually we aren't typing.
See,
so your performance declines until you get the more advanced thing down in your
head.
All of a sudden you can type 50 words,
60 words a minute.
That's a more advanced,
more efficient way of typing or writing.
So that's a good way.
I express that idea to people who may not be in business that simple way,
like that make sense?
That's why it doesn't make sense.
I'm trying to think.
So,
um,
so we,
you and I,
I don't know why,
but you and I immediately started training together like super hard all the
time.
You were,
you were one of the guys,
like I mentioned,
if I say that's of scary,
oh I got to do it.
Also,
if I say it would,
it would suck to be mounted.
I'll all purpose start mounted.
And if we brought a bounce,
most people,
Jocko was one of the few guys that if we wrote a bounds,
Andy and I have a good position on him,
he will insist we started an aisle,
I'll argue to actually like no,
put your arm back where it was.
Cause I actually want to have it reset to a what's harder for me.
So if I go to bounce the,
that I think that's why.
And uh,
first time I saw you Higgs,
he's like,
I have a friend named Jocko.
Man knew he gets involved.
He just kind of like men,
you'll know,
you'll see me Alice know and I'm like,
okay.
So I knew you were coming in and you walked in and he were like Roger Yet and
first day you got,
you got arm locked in and no emotion.
Just you sit like the term benchmark and just
this.
I was like,
Hey,
it's pretty hardcore,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
But you were training hard.
You training hard.
It was pretty hard too.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I remember,
I just remember like almost immediately I was training with you a lot.
Maybe it's cause we were,
I don't know.
We would,
we would spend three hours after Saturday talking on the mat about things and
techniques.
Like literally two hours open mat,
three hours more technique every Saturday.
That's Saturday.
Of course times were different back then.
Yeah.
I was going crazy thinking about the fact,
and there's,
so,
I don't know if this is,
you guys can tell me if this is insecurity or what,
but I like Higgs came to my house and Higgs was now Higgs had just got his
purple belt and he came to my house and he,
well he called me and said,
hey,
you want to train each look or you want to train?
And I said,
come on over man.
And you know I was bigger than Higgs and he was long and he's,
his legs go up to like his sternum.
So his legs,
he's like a reason you can too.
And Triangle.
Yeah.
And so he came over and we went in the grass across the street from the house
and he's just worked me over.
And I was like,
and so again,
you tell me if this is insecurity,
but I was like,
I never want to have another man be able to impose his will on me like that.
That is not the way I want to wait to look at things.
So by the time,
so I literally went down to Fabio's the next day and signed up and he's like,
do you want to try a class?
And I was like,
no,
I just want to sign up unlimited classes 165 bucks a month here,
take my money train.
And I remember,
I remember you couldn't go immediately into the advanced class.
You had to just take the beginner's class.
Yeah.
And I don't know if I talked to him or I told him like,
Hey,
I can't get her until later sometimes.
Can I just every go.
And He,
and he was pretty cool,
you know,
he just said,
yeah.
And then,
and so those times where,
you know,
I just wanted to learn as much as I possibly possibly,
possibly could because I didn't want to be at the of some other
human beings will.
Yeah.
It's an awful feeling.
There's some people that don't like that feeling and so they avoided completely.
Yeah.
That's actually the more common,
that's the more common reaction.
The more common reaction is,
oh,
I don't like that situation because I get dominated and I have to submit to
another man or woman by the way,
I have to submit to this other man or woman and I hate that.
So I'm just never going to get in this situation.
The problem is as we know in life,
you can't always avoid those situations and those situations can present
themselves and you can't do anything about it.
So,
so you and I just started training like maniacs.
Yeah.
And the thing I was thinking about for,
for some reason,
even in the beginning we did know,
gee,
we would take our gies off so many times we would get yelled at sometimes and,
and,
and for me,
luckily I would teach guys at and the teams and I w I just would always wear
Nogi.
I would just always wear a tee shirt and khaki pants.
That was like the standard.
Yeah.
I was like,
if you want to train,
yeah.
Tee Shirt,
khaki pants,
barefoot.
And so I was almost immediately training Nogi because I was training at the team
and I would be training guys even though we weren't highly skilled.
But I was at least understanding that there were some nuance differences cause I
didn't have the wrestling background that you had.
Yeah.
Well it's good because you know,
if you rely upon the uniform only and that's only how you're train no uniform,
how are you going to be?
Yeah.
So then the other big thing here is,
I mean we were competing a lot back then.
Yeah.
We were competing a lot and those old school Jujitsu tournaments were freaking
awesome back in the day.
They were,
they were super,
they were crazy.
They were crazy.
Just trash back in the day,
the Armenian guy and there was a riot.
Oh it was canon.
It was,
it was crazy.
500 resilience and like 20 Armenian guys.
And by the way,
my coach,
you had a thing with that coach and,
and I'm not going to say what he said,
but it wasn't very nice.
The guy actually took me down to zero.
It had me to fall,
like almost broke my foot,
but I escaped and I want Ethan to,
to like,
I was tough.
I'd beat them.
And Fabio is culture.
Oh Sir.
He's coaching me.
And of course the other coaches in Armenian seems to,
I don't speak Armenian,
but uh,
for some reason that guy is not an official Jujitsu guy.
More like a judo,
sambo,
whatever variant.
And right afterwards,
yeah.
And because of that,
there was a riot to Jujitsu.
I was,
because my match hundreds of hundreds of people chanting Jujitsu and the judo,
the Armenian guys were,
but they were actually,
they were great dudes.
And like it was like the Carl Friesian crew.
It was all those guys,
they were hard fighters.
They were telling were tough as hell.
And they were,
and they were,
uh,
connected to judo,
gene labella suits.
So it was like total respect.
But I respect there was respect.
I think that the disrespect came more from the Brazilian side and,
well,
I mean we were certainly associated with the Brazilians cause we had a Brazilian
coach when we were doing Brazilian Jujitsu.
But,
uh,
yeah,
there was some,
there was some mayhem,
but the guy car,
he was in Cairo and actually he's like a mathematician now.
I'm not going to fight anymore.
I'm a doctorate,
you know,
just
find some strange people in the sport.
I mean the way that guy,
he broke two people's feet,
this is back in the day when they let it was more hard core as it was.
It was,
uh,
it was,
it was disrespectful to,
to tap to a foot lock,
you know,
like,
oh,
you can't tap to that.
Uh,
you know,
those don't work.
You know,
that's not technically,
you shouldn't have to that.
So guys would just get their foot broken by these,
you know,
cause again,
what could you know,
Jean Luc,
Jean the bell,
I mean his,
his repertoire of super strong love of submissions is crazy and brutal.
And so all those guys were coming in with that whole game plus there,
whatever sambo background they had.
And there were some good,
good competitions in and it was total mayhem.
But,
so I was thinking like the Machado invitation,
which I think he won that like four or five times.
You have the champion,
the Gracie national,
you won that a bunch of times.
Yeah.
The grapplers quest back in the day.
That's still going to grapplers quest.
The group.
Remember the grappling games?
Remember neutral grounds.
That's,
that's the last one I had.
The last one I had was neutral grounds grounds.
That was in the hood.
It was in the hood in La and the cage,
somebody didn't finish the fence for correctly cut you.
There was,
I mean he was straight teach math like WWF back in deleting in this backyard and
there's like 200 guys who are just like,
uh,
no one's throwing anything but almost,
oh sorry.
Let me start.
I like like environment but not punches that day.
And those required,
Rico's was there.
He is.
I I win against Ricoh Rodriguez.
Yeah,
I lost,
um,
you didn't you go against well,
yeah.
Well let's see though.
I'm a good,
yeah,
I had two matches.
Higgs also,
we both want,
he'd be Hickson's guy.
Yeah,
he was,
he was like a beast.
He was,
he was one of the,
that was an incredible match because he eggs was kind of getting,
you know,
Higgs was a lot smaller than him.
Well maybe in a lot,
but he was 30 or 40 pounds smaller than him.
He has a little bit,
he's,
he's a very confident,
but he's a little more reserved and bows little more physically intimidating
looking is a core guy and exist.
And they went out of,
and then Higgs caught him in a triangle trying to arm lock.
Yeah,
that was nice.
And who,
yeah,
you would,
didn't you have a guy that like wouldn't give up?
Was that you?
Oh No,
that was Carl.
The same guy against Rico,
but not just unconscious where you wake up talking 30 seconds later unconscious
from a grappling match because coach is like,
oh,
he's fine.
He's okay.
He's like,
oh,
he's fine.
And he's like,
he's not in the movie.
And I'm like,
I think I see his chest moving also.
Like he's not dead.
And I'll be like,
are you sure?
He's,
I know he's trying,
he's trying to pick up the guy's like limp.
So tough than top to that head arm.
But match was over heading off frank,
two minutes.
Oh,
they're Armenian guys sandwich.
And that was what we called Rodriguez weighed 300,
300 pounds,
300 pounds.
[inaudible] 71 [inaudible] 70.
My face them,
I got to his back four times and he finally got me the head and arm and 300
pounds.
There's no joke.
He didn't get me in the head and arm.
Uh,
you and I remember you and I on this,
on this like random piece of carpet rolled out and then Allie before the fight
and were,
and you're,
you and me are just drilling because we knew it had an arm was his move.
And so you're just going head Norman.
And I'm getting out of it and getting out of it,
getting out of it.
But he got me in a,
um,
was it Geeky?
Yes it was.
He had spandex,
spandex bottoms and a guitar and he,
uh,
he got me in a,
in an a Zeke,
you'll from my half guard.
Yeah.
Which you don't,
you know the learning phases of Jujitsu and you go,
I didn't know that would work.
That was one of those for me.
I was like,
I didn't know that would work.
I didn't think it would work.
Like you can't put into Zeke,
you all me my half guard and then it work.
Yeah,
we did.
Just just a side tangent,
we're walking to the venue.
We parked two blocks down and Jocko had sunglasses on and there was these two
ghetto dogs.
Like these were pissed off at the or partials and chocolate went like this and
he stared at the August one wrong.
It's funny because I'm like 19 years,
you were probably like 25 and the dogs they were,
they weren't Robert real confident and you came that devil stare and they kind
of backed up.
There were still barking but immediately it was a fence between us.
But first time I seen a man just pumped to dogs with his eyeballs.
It was awesome.
Kind of motivated me.
Fit,
match actually,
you know what was pretty cool?
So this is one of my favorite Dean Lester stories.
You are going against again,
it was one of these crazy tournaments.
Total mayhem.
And so we're talking,
this is like 90 I don't know,
97 98 something like that.
Total mayhem.
And you would always get,
well you'd always be in the finals or the semifinals,
you know,
on your way to the finals because you would win every tournament.
It was freaking ridiculous.
Well not everyone,
but yeah.
Okay.
Not everyone,
but most of all I would do the absolute to it.
So I win my division and the absence.
No,
it was awesome.
And I would do my best,
which wouldn't be as good as Dave.
And so when he was deans in this match,
and he's going against this Brazilian kid and they are,
they're going at it and the Brazilian gets real,
super fiery,
right?
Super Five zillion guy slapping and he's going crazy.
And,
and you know,
it's really,
it's,
it's head touching,
but it's like a head slap.
You can hear the slaps happen and you can see this guy's going all crazy.
And he goes after dean,
like super hard trying to get a takedown.
And they fly across the mat and he's pushing and deans sprawling,
boom.
And they go way out into the stance.
I know I'm,
I'm the side like in his corner.
And so I just see the,
both of them disappear into the crowd and the crowd's going crazy and it gets
quiet and the guy comes out and he's all going crazy.
His all on fire and he's all,
he's like,
come on,
let's go.
And he goes to the middle of a mismatch and get on his knees and starts slamming
the Mat.
Ah,
like he's just so crazy.
And I,
and then I look at,
and then I looked back at the crowd where the hole was,
where they came.
Dean comes walking out and he's looks totally,
completely,
literally.
He looks like the Terminator.
He comes walking out,
no expression on his face.
Comes walking up to the middle of the mat and then the arm lock the guy like 20
seconds later and just the house.
That was pretty awesome.
That was good.
And then,
uh,
in,
in that time period,
right,
is when you do the ADCC trials?
Actually,
we both did.
ADCC Charles in 2003,
2002,
I won the,
the trials and then I ended up in Brazil.
I went to all but Dhabi,
I went to up Adobe.
It competed.
I didn't win that year.
I was a purple belt.
We did,
uh,
we did several big trial tournaments,
Sunday.
It didn't materialize into actual events.
We did several of these saints,
albeit the McCall fires that I think that was the first one.
2001 2002 I think it was 2002.
Yeah.
And it was here in San Diego,
right?
Yeah.
And I've got like Nice Health Club.
The hotel and Kenny Florian was there.
Ah,
Kenny Florian was there and he was super cool.
And uh,
yeah.
And I went against um,
big country related to country.
Matt Nelson and I think it were a division of like four to two or something.
Yeah.
And then you had just wars.
I had this all American wrestler,
I dunno.
Good restaurant that Nate do Charmaine and he slammed my knee.
I found out later that he does it on purpose.
He lets you get the back and he dives and spears and he in the ground and it
damages your knee.
Actually fist choke.
I registered impact or registered like that.
That kind of hurt.
But I didn't let go the truck when he tapped and I was like,
my knee doesn't feel correct and swelled up like this.
Like double the size and I put two epic to knee sleeves over it and I'm like,
I don't know why that's somehow focused me.
I didn't,
I didn't go,
oh,
I'm hurt.
Oh this is my excuse to quit.
I went,
you know,
it would be really cool.
There's some I did.
Doesn't three psychologically you like being the underdog kind of,
yeah.
Yeah.
I have less pressured.
I think most people would like to be the favorite.
I'd have to be the one that's like,
oh that guy can't win.
And so I had the guy from,
um,
what's his name from Henzel Gracie's from New York and he attacked my leg.
We're going after it and he had me straight in the lock and the reference about
stop.
I looked at record and went like this and he's shaking his legs.
He played my college ball cause we'll athletic Patterson,
Jamal Patterson.
And I got this back,
choked him and I see you in the corner.
Like you're lucky.
This evil grin just shines through the ground.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And then the layman was in the finals and I won by points that one on top of
Dhabi or went to Brazil.
That's also when,
that's also when Eddie Bravo was at the same trials.
He won the trials too.
Yeah.
So that was,
that was kind of a big deal.
And Dave trail one,
his and Dave Tyrrell's when his,
yeah.
And the one who won the heavyweight was in some country.
Boy,
I dunno,
I forget his name.
Yeah.
Once.
So we went down to Brazil and Eddie,
Eddie took third,
but he beat up hoarded ratio.
That was that,
that I got more attention than me winning the absolute yeah.
Ways that was,
well,
they think I'm,
for some reason,
I mean
towards her.
Yeah.
And,
um,
but yeah,
you went and won the absolutes,
which is,
you know,
it's freaking insane that you won the absolute Jocko train me so hard number.
The seven ups on the,
on the stairs shoving ups,
these Danes seven on the cross,
seven ups by seven ups is not like what it sounds like a pop money that's seven
times up the stairs and under what,
20 seconds,
20 seconds you do it again.
And I'm like,
that's my,
my invitation to Jocko Jocko would do this evil navy seal tactic on me where
dean jump up hit the bar and I'm like,
okay,
keep going.
Keep blowing warm too.
I'm like,
when are we gonna stop?
I don't know.
Jocko has some fictitious number in his head.
I have no idea.
But if I slow down it'd be like 99 100 101 I told on 199 and you,
I'm like,
I'm losing my ground.
I can't stop now because I'm going to die.
And the stairs was like,
yeah,
I'll put down seven times.
It wasn't a long stare with maybe three,
but it was like,
Yup,
you up and down in less than 30 seconds or you have to do it x amount of times.
And I got a good shape for that.
Then there was a good teams up in the top floor.
This is when we were at city boxing in downtown San Diego.
There was beams and pipes and like the beams were 14 inches taller than the
pipes up that you had to jumps.
I'd be like on the beam beam beam pipe pipe when he was getting exhausted I'd be
like pipe cause there's a little bit lower.
But yeah,
you were in sec shape and we were just grab that that time.
So uh,
at that time I was going to college.
Yeah.
So I
all I had to do,
I wasn't,
I was detached from the seal teams.
Yeah.
From 2003.
And all I was doing was going to college and all we did was train Jujitsu
actually.
Yeah.
And we would just train and just trained more and then just train after that.
Jack was such a maniac.
He's one of the few guys,
I'll say,
hey,
want to trade is six in the morning.
Tomorrow we'll be there at five 30 because we're not,
why be late?
You know,
how about nine 30,
nine o'clock at night?
Yeah,
sure.
Wow.
No,
you'll do it.
No problem.
Jocko helped me cut weight one time.
Remember this?
Uh,
it was funny at one e five for the belt,
it king of the cage and two weeks before the fight,
this is of course a fight now,
uh,
chocolates like dean,
you look kind of muscular,
like saint muscular.
You said you're looking a little beefy heavy,
like what's up?
And I go,
well,
you know,
fat probably did look a little headache.
And I went,
you,
well,
how much do you weigh?
I go,
I'm to 18.
And you went,
Dean,
um,
what weight are you fighting in?
In two weeks.
I want want to do five and a jock.
And went,
really?
Um,
don't you understand that 33 pounds is like an issue and I,
oh,
well my friend,
this is,
I was 24,
25 years,
my friend.
Tony's like,
Oh yeah,
you,
you lie down on the bathtub,
a full bet absent assault and he lose 20 pounds,
like in an hour.
No problem.
I'm like,
okay.
It's,
chuck was like,
did you try it yet?
I'm like,
no,
Dean,
mother lazy with it.
Get some Epsom salt,
try it tonight.
Let me know.
I'm like,
I'm all confident.
I go get Epson salt.
I guess alcohol like rubbed me,
I'll call you,
pour it in the bath.
I don't know,
30 minutes later I get out.
I lost like half a pound and might not 20 half of can I go?
I called Jocko doors.
Like what happened or input or something.
Something,
something,
something military like report.
Yes.
Reconnaissance.
Whatever.
Field report.
So,
so I'm like chocolate.
How much did you lose your mother?
You know,
make,
uh,
I think I was like three quarters of,
I think I had,
I think I exaggerate.
Three quarters.
Yeah.
It was like your mother maybe at the beach by the house is with both.
How they don't know.
We're all long branch and six in the morning and I go there and John was like,
you know,
the next two weeks you could have like a can of tuna per day and we're going to
run in three hours.
Draka ran it with me,
by the way.
Most people won't do that.
Oh,
I don't watch you run.
You ran me.
We ran all around point Loma in.
By the way,
we're going to the beach and I'm like,
oh,
we're going to run on beach chocolate just over little sea wall.
It's run at the beach,
can kind of close to water and uh,
in the water.
I'm like,
okay.
It's like on the water,
chocolate swimming and these cliffs and I'm,
I'm like,
I'm trying to catch up with them on,
I'm not as seal swim.
Right.
My,
I'm a strong swimmer and I'm not usually like flippers,
flippers.
I thought he did it though.
He's out in the surf going runs cliff.
So I'm like,
okay,
I've done that before,
but he's ahead of me.
I'm like tired.
Like this sucks because I'm already not eating and whatever.
Plus,
uh,
I was younger.
So you know when you're younger,
things suck more than when he older.
You realize it didn't suck that bad because you're older,
you have these experience.
So from a fair run all the way to mission beach,
we're across the bridge.
We sram through that.
Well not a very clean river,
just went through.
But the San Diego River,
we've found through their three hour run,
not every day,
maybe for two weeks all the time.
And I,
I lost 18 pounds and then of course I lost 15 pounds of water and I made the
weight.
That was terrible.
That was harder to cut a,
now it's a hard and I fought a tough guy too.
So yeah,
those anyone,
yeah.
Yeah it was a,
it was a good day.
You know what?
I got to go back to the,
uh,
when you won ADCC in Brazil cause that was freaking amazing.
So there's a couple things.
Number one,
one of the guys that you faced was a guy named,
paid upon.
Oh yeah.
And,
and I was reading so I couldn't go down cause I was in college at the time.
And it was right in final exams.
I couldn't,
I literally could not go down with you.
And so you were down there by yourself in Brazil in enemy territory and you're
down there.
And so I'm reading,
there's something called the,
it's the underground,
it's the,
it's the m is the mixed martial arts.com.
It's the Ugi which also has the Oji.
So it's,
it's an old forum,
which still exists to this day.
It used to be called submission fighting.
And actually you and I,
when I was on deployment like way back then,
you and I would communicate,
we didn't have email,
so I would communicate on submission,
fighting.com and the threads and the struggle.
Yeah.
And uh,
so I'm reading,
so what they're doing is someone is translating like an some kind of automatic
termination,
watching them posting what it's saying.
And so it was like a literal,
the Americans in trouble.
Yeah,
no,
it was a literal,
it was a literal translation and so paid upon,
oh,
means cloth foot,
is that right?
Yeah,
but it's actually,
it's a car clunkier care something.
Yeah.
Well,
this guy paid upon him was a guy that our instructor,
Fabio,
he's unbeatable.
He paid upon was this massive guy and he was sick black belt in Jujitsu.
And he's like,
yeah,
this guy will never be beaten because he's so massive and he's so good at
Jujitsu.
No one could score points on him.
Usually he was just a dominator.
And how has anyone are going to be something that's that big and that skilled.
And so dean,
so I'm reading,
I remember I'm sitting in the parking lot of home depot for some reason and the
match is going on and I'm reading,
I'm refreshing it on my phone and it's popping up and it's slow.
It's like back in the day,
right?
Reception's bad.
And I'm reading it in it.
And I remember this thing,
it says that it says the cloth foot has a choke in deep.
The American must have a tube to his lungs because he is not tapping.
And I was like,
yes.
And then you beat him and a man you beat and then you went on a one that was a,
that was a big deal,
man.
Yeah,
he beat,
I mean,
he beat a bedroom that day and then well in their own division and uh,
but he cheated in that match.
Oh,
by the way,
pit upon was the only guy,
he wouldn't shake my hand.
You not talking to smack.
He just wasn't a very gracious,
uh,
you know,
by the way,
you can tell a lot about a person,
how,
how they conduct themselves when they win and all Saudi Lewis.
So by the way,
he was smashing me when the points didn't count.
My buddy,
he was 40 pounds heavier than he said,
big guy,
six foot six,
six foot,
seven foot,
six,
260,
70 pounds.
And uh,
but he,
he,
uh,
he won against very to him,
but he cheated.
I saw the tape and he put his arm on.
Uh,
it wasn't a submission out of balance each.
He did,
whenever we started the crowd,
the crowd was ingredient,
a submission about,
he was in trouble.
He wasn't,
he was on the verge of it being locked in,
but he kind of moved his arms.
So He wa he started in a more favorable position.
So that was the one match where the Brazilians were kind of cheering for me.
Otherwise,
no,
they're caring for the other Brazilians,
but so when I wanted to people,
so who was the first match against?
What's match was Nate Marquardt Neymar court and I got to get in my Camaro.
Tough guy.
Yeah.
Awesome.
God that was brutal.
Yeah.
Sallow here.
Barrel and then Solo and the salad was already at five time world champion at
the time I was a brown belt,
so it was kind of,
for me,
it was weird.
I,
I had less pressure in the harder division,
uh,
where I was.
Last guy was number 16 of the world.
Um,
it was,
I dunno why he just will you like I said,
you like to be the underdog.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't,
I wish I could describe what happened that day because if I could replicate
that,
I don't know what happened.
Eric Paulson said,
he said Dean had a golden aura around and I saw it.
I don't see auras yet,
but I'm working there one day.
I want to see you like that gift.
And so these guys,
I mean sallows like,
like you said,
five times more.
I mean he's just one of the best in his boss's brothers,
Raji and John History,
both awesome,
unbelievable Jujitsu players.
And then you,
and then it was paid upon him.
And then in the finals it was cockeyed eight who was cockeyed Eiko at a handy
for Hara.
And He,
uh,
he's a beast.
He,
he's known for,
he actually was a good sport,
but he,
he,
he had the reputation that Tokyo has today.
He would hurt people actually.
Footlocker,
John G that day he guilty and completed that day and he beat for abusive or do
them also just by Quincy at the same guy,
eight zero five zero and then fiber sub be paid upon.
Oh,
and that third fourth match.
So that was Kinda like,
uh,
you know,
this is payback here,
so he went,
so it was a good day.
And the finals,
I was told this guy has the best gilts in the world and the best foot locks in
Brazil for sure.
And he's the best wrestler in Brazil.
So I'm like,
I thought about it like,
who is,
Oh,
be careful as guilty.
And I thought to myself,
I'm not trying to act courageous,
nothing like that,
but I said to myself,
that would really suck.
And I go,
I kind of,
maybe you could feel how is guilty and his,
you know,
and so I grabbed his legs and he went for,
and I was like,
let me see how it is.
Not that I wanted it.
Yeah.
Kind of.
I wanted to escape it.
It's kind of weird anyway,
and to play with the fire and it wasn't,
yeah,
that was in it.
And he really,
I hear,
I hear the crowd yelling and I hear the crowd gets silent because he has me so
tight,
not where my ears,
but I'm getting choked really somehow.
I'm,
I guess I'm slightly resistant to submissions.
I heard.
And um,
and I,
I'm just thinking like I could see the light at the tunnel and uh,
as he started getting a little tired and as soon as elbow on his could,
technically that was the reason,
but I maybe just resistant,
echo something.
Um,
so he eventually got tired,
let go,
and I saw his eyes.
He was just,
I got him,
I knew at that moment.
And then we started in the middle and I went for a full lock and he was real
calm for luck and that 50,
50,
we didn't call it 50,
50.
Then I said let's try it.
And I did it and his eyes,
you could see he doesn't know what's coming function and he would iie tap,
well more of a macho.
I,
I got him.
And then of course I actually couldn't believe it at the moment because I would
probably use,
well it's the equivalent of the Olympics for our sport and it's the,
there are Olympic wrestling in Abu Dhabi.
There's sambal geysers only judo guys.
Best Jiu Jitsu guys are in this and a whole world's invited and the winner gets
40 g's baby.
So there's no other tournament that pays how much I was 27.
That was a lot of money man.
Your legs a on yeah.
Yeah,
it is easy.
Yeah.
And uh,
it was funny.
Uh,
so I'm,
I'm number 16,
but I have no co Margarita came down the coach saying you're number 16,
you were in the number six toes seed.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's how you ended up being one.
But so I'm worried I have no coach until Margaret came down for the last three
matches.
I'm shadow boxing.
I have no,
everyone's wrestling with the coach.
I'm just like shadowbox I'm like a Weirdo.
I by the way,
I didn't think I was going to be in the tournament,
so I wore my Bridgeland entitys cause I don't usually fight or compete in those.
I use the word sip trunks,
but I'm like God,
in case I'm invited,
I'll put my sweatpants over you.
So I'm in like basically speedos warm me up shadowboxing,
all want yourself.
And I look up and there's just only Brazilian girls looking down at me.
Like,
and I'm like going down and one girl goes,
hey,
come here in that,
I shouldn't have done it.
But you know,
this girl could have been on lung on the cover of a magazine and
she said,
hey,
how you doing?
Portuguese was not that good back then.
I was like,
oh,
I'm good.
How are you?
And she said in Portuguese,
Oh,
you're not resilient,
how are you?
And I said,
no.
And she went and she turned her back and walk.
She called me over and then turn the ways jacked up.
So I'm like,
all right,
mister chops up,
focus,
focus.
And then I got through this.
And then at this moment,
I don't know why this is,
but the champion gets like 95% of the attention.
The Guy who took second is equal level of me.
Maybe it could be me a different day.
I must admit,
I'm not gonna say it can never lose to that guy.
He's really good.
But I have align
a thousand people waiting to meet me and take pictures with me.
So I'm in the,
I'm still on my Brisbane's tidy.
So you know,
and uh,
I'm glad you guys like,
Hey,
what's up?
Hey girls.
Hey kids.
You know,
I can picture it.
And after half hour I see this girl,
like eight people don't go on like,
hi,
remember me?
Hi.
And I'm like,
I'm like mental note.
Like so sh she waits.
She waited like an hour to meet me and she finally within earshot,
she's like in Portuguese murmur me.
Hey,
I knew you could do it.
She's Spanish,
Portuguese.
And I'm like,
yeah,
whatever.
She gets up to me and I'm sure I was guy would've would've caved in to this.
But I,
I skipped her just like that.
And uh,
she had this little puppy dog look,
this hurt ice on it.
That was like,
you either try Jan moral victory of that game.
It was awesome.
So the walk when,
when you were doing that,
I remember in when you getting ready for that,
first of all,
we trained freaking hard like crazy.
And I remember sarge since to push you hard as hard as we possibly could.
Like sarge cause starts a better wrestler than me.
He would do the take downs with you and then as soon as you guys would hit the
mat,
I would jump on top and that way and get,
get you just as tired as we get you.
But also I didn't think about it this way,
but man,
a lot of times when you and I would be training,
like we would just sit there and try and foot lock each other for just a half an
hour.
I mean it would be like it's,
which is weird because now that's very common to see in one was really doing
that actually.
Yeah,
no one was doing it back then and now you see tournaments and that's what the
tournament is.
It's just a bunch of people trying to foot lock each other and l sit there,
he will hook for luck and when,
when we were doing it,
that's why like when I look back on,
I was like no one was doing that.
You would never see anyone sit there and trade foot locks and heal hooks for 20
minutes as we're,
we're actually rolling trying to submit each other,
but we're just trading and trading and trading.
And that gave you such an advantage when,
you know,
you knew moves,
you had techniques that were just no one even understood the position.
And now you hear a John Danaher talking about it,
you know,
and I heard John Donahoe her talking about the fact that,
he teaches his guys to get people in a position that the other person isn't
comfortable with.
Right?
And that's,
that's what you were doing weight way back then was,
hey,
I'm going to take you to somewhere that you do not understand what's happening
and you will be confused and I'm going to crush you.
And on top of that,
you know,
your natural,
like I said,
a mutant skills and all that.
And it just turns into a while.
I guess it turns into world championship is when it turns into that was a good
day,
you know,
uh,
the,
it became what I won with the 50,
50.
I didn't,
I didn't have a name for that position.
I,
I was reading Portuguese from some respectable older guy who's homeless,
their names.
But people I looked up to were saying,
basically,
this is a disaster.
This green Goo Griego means foreigner.
It's not a slur,
just means 400 Zam foreigners coming down here.
This is not Jujitsu.
What the hell repeated by different people.
And I'm like,
okay,
well,
you know,
I looked at my gold medal in my trophy and I'm like,
I don't feel so bad actually.
But that three months later I hear about a position called the 50 50 I'm like,
I want to see it and I'll go,
oh,
now it's accepted.
It's a Brazilian move now.
Yeah.
Also won the move.
I got a solid one.
No one was doing that knee lock now.
Now it's commonplace.
A Crowbar,
I forget if it was you or me that came up with the idea,
but you for sure Kim,
the name Crowbar.
I heard in Russia the a crowbar and they're doing cobra with a cage.
I'm like,
man,
that's been around.
So like the man,
all these kinds of things.
Um,
you know what?
Maybe someone's done it before me,
but you brought it a legit actual military gas mask on their treadmill or like
do you put it on like what the hell?
I just,
I looked like late from a damn horror movie like Montreal.
And so now everyone's worn gas,
Mac dream mass.
When did these aren't real gas man,
this is actual,
I'm running.
I was like,
if you're slow down,
we're adding another 20 minutes.
Okay.
I did it.
I didn't complain.
But yeah,
we were like doing stuff before most people.
It was,
it was good times.
That was pretty awesome.
And also at this whole time period,
you were also fighting MMA and you were king of the cage.
You fought a bunch of fights and king of the cage,
you were in the middle weight champion and King of the cage pretty.
And then that's when King of the cage was sort of the feet or organization for
pride,
which was when pride was,
the equivalent was number one UFC until everyone in the world,
you know,
it was,
it was very,
very popular.
The fights were awesome.
They had the best fighters.
Um,
well I can't say they had the best fighters because they had,
they had equivalent fighters of,
I think they were one notch at that time.
I think there were one notch above you,
some of them.
But some of them came to the UFC and didn't do as well as well as with the pride
and it work both ways at different rules.
Say it's equivalent,
I won't say it's better,
but it was definitely,
it was definitely so you were in the feed or organization for pride and then,
and then you went to private,
but he had the cage was third.
It was considered the third hardest in the world.
Yeah,
it was.
Well I don't even think,
yeah,
Al underneath that was just completely unknown things.
And you and I got lucky because uh,
well I got lucky because I was hanging out with you and we would go to Japan and
we saw some pretty,
pretty crazy fights in Japan too.
My goodness.
The stories we have,
remember that,
remember that time we were his pool hall?
Like it's late night,
one 30,
and I dunno,
whatever it was benign.
Maybe we're playing pool and there's this a VIP area.
It's actual a pool lounge and there's a big Japanese bodyguard there.
What's beyond our music and stuff?
And they just try to get in there.
He's like,
he's like,
like,
I guess that means no,
you can't come in and we're just Harrington hoists.
That's when that's when he lost to your
sheet.
Oh yeah.
He's come by with a bunch of,
um,
let's say connected Japanese,
uh,
friends and he sees us.
He goes,
hey,
dean shotgun and gets his in there and it's,
it's like a Karaoke lounge.
And it was Lionel Richie's a voice coach
was singing there.
It was just nuts.
And,
um,
dude,
I met Lionel Richie's voice building.
What's out,
what's the time that we saw?
So seeing those big fights in Japan and when we saw no gira fight,
Bob Sapp,
so no bureau was no gears to 100 or 230 pounds,
maybe 200,
350.
Yeah.
Bob Sapp 350 pounds.
He beat the living crap out of no Gira for however long.
Seven minutes.
Yeah.
And then no gear.
Got Him in an arm lock.
Omoplata sweep arm locked.
That was clear.
The army,
it wasn't the national stadium.
There's like 120,000 people on the crowd.
They had kettle drums.
Do you know what those are?
Echo,
you know what a kettle drum is?
Just big giant drums and then ways that troop of Japanese drum players.
So when this thing kicked off,
these guys are surrounding the top of the stadium with kettle drums,
Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo,
Doo Doo.
It was on fire and dean and I were there,
you know,
and we flew,
actually flew over with,
with voice for those things and them was there I think.
Yeah,
that's right man.
It was just,
I think Bergen was in the walkout entourage or something.
You know,
he was somewhere else.
But it's guys or parachuting in like remember that?
Oh yeah,
I would say in is,
yeah.
He's like,
he has a camera,
it's like [inaudible] at 20,000 feet and he's like,
I'm falling.
And it was like,
and they come down and they landed like in the ring.
It was procurious he was crazy.
And then you ended up for,
you know,
obviously since you were the king of the cage champion,
you ended up going to pride,
you got sick fights and pride.
You fought,
uh,
will you beat so g yeah.
And he was uh,
he was like a warrior and then you got a beast of a fight against a Rona.
I also face to,
oh,
and then I,
I,
well I didn't get to fight Paula Philo,
he,
because he got his,
um,
you guys lake broken.
Um,
but I also fought job.
I'm also,
they're from Russia.
Sounds like some of these things sound like I'm making them up.
But he legitimately became a hit man for the Russian something.
The syndicate.
Russia killed a couple politicians and the arrested him because apparently you
can't do that.
And does,
he confirmed he died in prison of cancer.
And in Russia,
if you kill a few politicians,
they just go,
we're not going to take care of your cancer too much.
He did that right away.
He died.
I died like two years ago.
So He's in prison.
That guy you've seen him before.
His nose was just probably broken.
That guy became a hit man.
And so I fought that guy and uh,
I Rona was,
that was our match.
That wasn't,
I'll take ownership of this situation.
I'm not,
I'm not making excuses,
but explanation wise it was not,
I was not my normal self for that fight,
but it was our fight.
I lost my decision.
It was good.
It was 100,000 people in the crowd was awesome.
That was you walked down Z and Shandy?
Yeah.
Go.
Yeah,
my friend Tim.
All right.
Tim Comas,
Tim,
Tim Comas now.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Back then it was,
Yeah,
he uh,
he me,
I walked into one of the songs
and Hans was there.
It was good.
It was good times till Brent who was there and then,
and then eventually you get picked up by UFC.
So I transferred it the right time.
2005 six I just transferred.
It was a perfect time to transfer actually.
They had some good scraps.
I was actually going overseas now cause I was backwards team for awhile.
So I was kind of out of the,
uh,
out of the fight game for a little bit.
It was still training.
Yeah.
Training when I was with you.
But um,
you had a bunch of fights in UFC by the way.
Make sure that I,
I don't forget to tell the kill Jocko story.
I've got to tell that story later,
but we'll just tell her right now.
Well,
I'll see it but,
but um,
okay.
So I was not,
I mean there wasn't pride at the time.
Jocko went to Afghanistan.
You were somewhere.
I think it was good.
I think it was my first deployment to Iraq for a couple of months and then it
was maybe I was just doing it.
Maybe if we,
I'm not sure.
But you were gone and you come back and my mom had this medication,
I had acne and it was some kind of antibiotic helped it,
but I didn't know.
It made me really weak and uh,
took my endurance away.
This is actually true.
This is not an excuse to this
chocolate comes back and I'm,
I'm not really feeling like a trunk was.
I was trained on Michael.
Okay.
And Jog would that kicks my ass and chocolates.
Like literally he's angry.
He's like,
you lazy more than I'm in the desert.
I'm doing this and you,
you're sitting on your ass here and sandy will do nothing and I kicked your ass
in w and I'm like,
Eh,
I'm just like,
I'm not ashamed of myself cause cause and then you go away for like a month or
somewhere you're gone.
And I'm like,
but that medication were at 10 days and I stopped taking it.
I feel strong again.
I'm like,
oh I understand now.
So I'm training.
I'm like,
mother,
when the kid comes back,
I can't wait for this.
I made a CD
kill Jocko was had like corn and Metallica all he was like,
and so John came and I'm like,
Hey Jocko.
And I put this in and we trained in,
that was my day,
I guess.
I think I was like talking shit to you.
Like you,
my feelings were hurt and here's what socks for me is.
So if,
if both of us are on point,
I'm get,
I'm catching a beat down.
If so,
if both of us are bringing our a game on,
catching a beat down,
if deans bringing his a game and I'm bringing my week game,
I'm catching a beat down.
If I'm bringing my full a game and beans having a horrible day,
I could do like barely Oh Canada.
So it's like
the day,
the really good days that I have are,
are very few.
I have to,
I have to earn them.
I'll put it through that way.
And um,
then so,
so you do UFC,
you do decent Ufcu had some tough fights,
good fights,
three,
four ranked in my division,
my law,
my only two losses by decision was named Mark Ward and you shall call me.
And they both after that fight fire and the silver.
So I was two times right.
They're fighting for the belt.
I was top five top,
no,
I don't care tops.
But I fought to fight his silver and I lost both of his matches,
but the four I want.
And uh,
my first ride was Elissa Sakara who's from Italy's really tough fighter fat,
probably the fastest hands.
And actually I figured this out later.
I was the underdog,
but they were actually trying to feed me to him.
He was gonna fight chocolate all out.
Who you are stepping stone?
Well supposedly yes,
supposed to van de this group,
they're already planning like he's in a fight.
Chocolate l cause see I probably he has faster hands.
Probably Chuck has a really good chin,
better wrestling,
but Sacara it faster hands,
better boxing.
So I'll have them fight after is what I heard.
But um,
that day I got in the same triangle.
It shows you a cure in and uh,
but he taught the children here went to sleep.
So both my debuts won't one by the same move and uh,
against a tough guys.
So then I find out that the Japanese opponent,
I fight a Bulgarian Olympic wrestler,
I fought Nate Marquardt,
you should have called me and I fought Jeremy Horn.
So six fights in UFC.
So my career has been focused on Jujitsu more Nogi is because when you do MMA,
you don't,
you don't have a g or a chemo on one.
So it kind of wasting your time.
If you're training and that aspect and you don't have a gauge on your car,
how to grab the belt,
how to do this,
kind of wasting your time.
So yeah,
I've distributed my time between mixed martial arts and grappling Jujitsu.
And you weren't done either cause you went back in 2011.
Yeah.
You went back and well 2009 was that 2000 and thousand nine we were in
Barcelona,
Spain,
Barcelona and um,
yeah I was just well coming out by surgery.
It wasn't my,
it wasn't my year.
Yeah.
And those were some close matches having,
I was thinking about it the double overtime to Vinnie Magalia.
Yeah.
And we've next year and we both want our divisions well middle.
So his first match in the absolute and he had wine.
It was double overtime,
zero,
zero and well,
yeah.
The judges were looking at other,
like they raised his hands.
Did he have an Aluma plot on you or did you ever knew him?
I think that's why he won because I item two foot luxe.
Oh that's right.
You had him in two foot Luxy at him and he only went about doing pods and more
Jujitsu Ish,
I think that's why.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
yeah,
2011.
I don't know why.
Probably it was a harder tournament,
but I'm not saying it wasn't easy.
[inaudible] Nora came back.
You don't know why?
I don't,
I have no idea why,
but I,
yeah,
I just showed up and first match.
It was hard match.
Actually my friend,
I'll Cousteau Ferrari from Sao Paulo,
Brazil.
Very tough guy.
Um,
I thought that I'm top three or four seated right.
I was wrong.
He was,
he was like three and I was number 14 because now I'm 30,
I'm 35 and he was like 25 or like others get this old guy out of here.
Yeah,
knock him out of this thing I want,
I'm like,
that was the one,
the lowest rent guys.
That was a hard match.
My points.
The second guy was the European champion.
I feel locked in like two minutes and then we have one day to rest and I'm
facing a rental.
Javier,
who's total be someone can beat this guy.
He's like 21 and I'm 35 and this,
it was,
it was a not marching in England.
I can't,
I can't do that accent,
dammit.
But Nottingham England,
we were there and at the hotel I popped my rib.
I didn't want him to know my ribs pop.
Like during the batch a derm match with the Polish guy.
Orotic Turik European champion who he tried for loving me.
And it turned out it had popped my rib and I got his heel and I'm like,
my rib is unsat.
It's,
it's not,
it's not up to,
it's not up to standards,
you know?
So I'm like,
it hurts right now and I'm warm.
So I sat down and waiting for everyone to leave the arena so they wouldn't see
me.
You're like an Olympian home to the hotel.
So I didn't want to see,
you know,
appear strong when you're weak every week when you're strong.
So I was,
let's say we at the moment,
and I don't want people to see that.
So I got kind of walk real slow back to hotel.
And there's guys downstairs,
hey dean,
you're,
you're facing rural feared mom.
Like,
yeah,
do you know how good that guy is?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I heard no.
Do you actually understand what you're getting yourself into?
I'm like,
okay,
just stop it man.
It's just get the fuck,
get away from me.
And uh,
and uh,
I'm like trying to get my head kind of motivated me actually.
I like the a feeling like,
oh,
would you like to be an underdog man,
next day I showed up.
Oh.
And I saw [inaudible] he was competing with,
with spandex on.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
because it's harder to slip out of leg locks mixed day,
no shirt and no Spanish.
So someone told them something.
So I faced him and yeah,
he's,
you know,
he's like the future of the sport.
Awesome.
A great sport as well.
But it got him into,
but I think four minutes,
I got his heel in the four 11 which no one was doing and I'm moment.
So my 55th and for 11,
it was two of my nine lives of innovation that after I,
I did that.
People started doing it.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course when I did it,
no one understood what was going on.
And so if he was like,
it's like a secret weapon just to see that vision.
And then Joanna cease also,
he beat John G.
I took them down a mountain at him.
So beat someone like John g Joel sees is also super high level and uh,
but see mental mental games.
Um,
I'm older,
10 years older than,
than Joelle.
So I went to,
now at the time I speak good Portuguese,
so I'm in his corner was Leo Zinio via,
and Leo knows me,
he knows what for luck guy.
So,
so I'm like,
and I heard that Joie has good foot Luxton whatever it is.
So I'm,
I'm kind of talking like to him,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm a keep saying,
my foot's right here.
Come on.
And I'm a weekly and my feet like in his armpit,
like,
go for it.
And he's like,
he goes,
I don't think so man.
And then Lee was like,
no,
but I could see before the match.
It's like he's not,
he's not cocky,
but I could see he has a little pride.
I can just tell him he's younger than me,
so I'm like,
I'm played that.
I came,
I'm like,
that'll put you on my game.
You know,
he has good full marks,
but that's my board's Forte.
Let's see.
So eventually I'm like,
hey man,
this right here,
I heard you have good full lux.
I was too much.
He went from my foot and then I go,
what do you do?
You
see the thing is like right when he got older,
you got to use those little tricks.
You know sometimes you did that thing where when they go for your foot and that
opens up punching,
punch me,
I'll punch you back.
But yes,
but I have to be confident I can take a punch.
Right.
Well,
I'm somewhat confident that I can resist a leg lock or countering time and,
and it all worked.
You know,
it's funny because I'm sitting here laughing at laughing at that.
But you do that to me.
Yeah.
And know you don't.
You don't fall for it though.
Yeah,
but then I will.
Yeah.
Eventually I'll be like,
fuck,
I can get dressed and I'll just go for it and then you'll,
you'll get yolk for wrong me from,
yeah,
exactly.
I get that's junk.
Was Sin went back again in 2013 for the GCC again,
it took silver to Jamal.
He won that year.
How anywhere I went for and I talked the referees afterwards.
It wasn't their fault.
I went for like a lock and he was I exact moment to suite me.
I did it wrong though.
I got greedy that time.
He had the arm position.
I went for the wrong move.
Technically,
if the referees knew I was going for legal,
like it's not as sweet,
but I was up.
I've got my points by one point I haven't been triangle and he's really strong.
He's flexing his ladder.
I'm like,
I have 30 seconds.
I'm not,
I haven't been locked and triangle,
but it was hard.
I was on the opposite side.
I'm like,
you know what he's doing?
The muscle is out one by one point.
So I opened up my full guard from the bottom,
turning my stomach.
He got my back.
So we actually won a four,
four,
four.
So you're trying to,
yeah,
because otherwise I can mentally be like,
you know what little thoughts racing through your mind.
You know,
I,
I can,
I know I'm going to lose,
but I would say I would have submitted them like,
you know,
but I'm going to lose the only chance I have really,
unless I had been there two minutes.
Then it's different.
So I had to take a chance.
It's a one in 10 chance and it didn't pay off.
It took silver.
I was really upset about taking solar,
but in the end up Adobe silver is not too bad.
Right?
No.
Your second best in the entire world.
The reason it's pretty time gold.
One time silver.
And then you did the absolute that year too.
Oh,
did right.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's one of my favorite matches that you've ever done as against Chacha.
You wish lost.
It was tied up zero,
zero for nine minutes and eat.
He was like 22 I'm 35 and now I'm 37 now.
And Man,
it was how it was this weird cause I wasn't intimidated.
But yeah,
he's very healthy.
He's got east,
but people were user was strong and athletic.
Read technical.
Someone's like,
okay,
be careful this.
I'm like,
be careful.
I'm going to give,
I'm going to give him my leg.
You know her.
I just walk out hopping after on my leg and he's like,
what the hell?
And he grabbed my leg,
took it up.
There's no points.
He had meetings to Smith.
I am three submissions.
It was awesome at the end I took them down,
got mounted,
but my foot was stuck so it didn't count any Oupa
whoops me shoulder roll and Portuguese over.
That's two points in Abu Dhabi we'll put means.
And actually it actually means shoulder roll or is that just,
I thought it was just a noise that thought made everyone's,
that's all.
Bye.
Oh,
okay.
Buys is shorter.
Well,
but if you talked to someone that doesn't do Jujitsu,
open doesn't mean shoulder.
All it means is Jitsu term.
Okay,
oop.
I mean shoulder,
we'll,
yeah.
Oh,
escaped him out.
So he did that and he's the one Dan Brazilian who has a wrestler bridge.
Like he brushed up on it,
it took me over and I'm like God damn.
And I know that move for like when I was 14 years old but he took me over and I
was in my full guard.
He's up to zero.
Anyone like that?
So it was a good match.
Good match that's on Youtube.
Go Watch that match.
If you want to just see we were exhausted out of that will.
That is,
that is just a beast of a match.
It's a beast of an I could not,
I'm going to say cool.
Yeah.
Couldn't when my shoulders afterwards and I'm like this is gonna suck.
It's weird cause you had injuries along the way obviously,
but like you write it how many knee surgeries if you had to and,
but those were when you were pretty young,
right?
Yeah,
but I got older.
It's like my shoulder on my bicep.
You were there in the gym on my bicep snapped.
That was terrible.
It's boring.
What I go listers done under.
Usually done?
Yeah,
undisputed.
it was the guy was blocking with his elbow.
He's trying to knock me out,
so I was like,
oh,
I'll knock you out.
Then just wanting to honor wasn't really warm yet and I hit his elbow with my
bicep snapped.
Terrible.
I'm like,
I didn't know you could snap your bicep,
but you can.
Yes.
You confirmed.
Yeah.
Double,
double confirmed.
What do you do when you win?
Like when you've got an injury?
What's,
what's your philosophy around trying to get it to heal?
Because people get injured during Jiu Jitsu or you know,
it's,
it's difficult for me because,
but I could try to make it as simple as possible.
See Jujitsu,
boxing,
any kind of a confrontational thing,
which you are an expert in and the military,
but also in Jujitsu.
I mean even if it's not a fun because you're getting smashed,
you're not bored,
you're not bored.
So we can't train Jujitsu.
Me Now I know we're different.
I personally don't like looking at myself in the mirror.
I don't like that at all.
But with weights,
I,
I get bored.
Personally.
I want to have someone trying to Herzmark and they don't want to get hurt,
but that at least I can be mentally immersed in,
in the issue.
Um,
so that makes our,
for me so personally I,
I focused on other things like learning languages or traveling or doing
seminars,
things like that.
How many languages do you speak all at once?
Out Team speaks seven languages.
I speak three in the way that I can make jokes.
I can argue and I can spell well I can write and I could read a Portuguese,
Spanish and English French.
I can,
uh,
I can have a conversation,
but I'm not smooth.
I have a big accent.
I couldn't make jokes and I couldn't effectively argue unless I to sound like
more at a nice,
I can,
I can do that.
Maybe I was sound like Croatian was a musical core crops coach,
uh,
for like seven years.
Like survival.
Like I want to go there.
How are you like,
you know,
so three or four or five,
depends on your definition.
Even German.
I can kind of get around a little bit,
but it's just on the street asking for directions and stuff like that,
but it's not good.
So three,
I guess three.
I'll say three.
Three solid.
Let's talk some Jujitsu philosophies,
sheets,
GI or no GI.
That's like saying,
um,
what do you like doing better?
A long distance runner versus a sprinter or a judo versus wrestling.
Uh,
kickboxing and boxing.
There's different sports.
They're related.
There's similar,
there's a lot of mechanical similarities.
So Oak,
he is better for,
uh,
it does help you to get a tighter of style,
but if you're wasting not wasting the saying,
yeah,
yeah.
If you're going to be doing Nogi,
and I know,
I know some,
I don't know if anyone watching knows,
knows the significance of this.
A wrestler knows right away this is wrong.
This is,
uh,
this is the,
a gable grip.
This is the script.
They're fine.
This is the BS grip.
It doesn't work.
A lot of world champions,
the only train all over a sleeve and belt.
They grabbed like this because they're taught to rely upon the uniform.
So if you rely upon the uniform and you don't have the uniform,
now 80% of your tools are gone.
So I think it's good to do both.
It's normal to prefer one over the other,
but don't discount,
uh,
no.
Gies more technical and faster and the transitions.
Absolutely.
And the fact that you can slip out of something easier means,
I'd say a transition to the next move faster,
but GE has more options.
I have many chokes I can do,
I can grab my own belt,
wrap it around your wrist.
You can't do that without Ge.
Uh,
so that's only,
so some people say,
some people will say,
gee is more technical,
but I don't believe that it's more technical.
Different.
There might be,
I guess,
no,
I was going to say maybe there's more techniques,
but there is not theirs.
It's equal.
I just think they're equal.
Yeah,
they're equal and technical because to hold someone down with the Geek as a lot
easier and you get someone across side with the g,
like you're going to hold them down.
You get across side and someone with Nogi,
it's a lot harder to hold him down because there's nothing to hold onto and so
it makes it harder.
That's why I think Nogi made sure office better.
He makes your defense.
Yeah,
that makes it harder to slip kind of things.
If you're in a submission with Ge,
it's hard to slip out of the,
you know,
you can get lucky.
It's really hard.
You're not really going to slip out of things.
Also,
if you're training with wrestling shoes,
it's different.
If you ate with the fatigues,
it's different training with the marines,
the team guys or a train the police,
whatever done in Brazil as well.
I mean they train like how there aren't duty,
you know?
So having someone with a,
you know,
fatigues on,
you still call the fatigues and no,
no.
Yeah,
I usually just go into Cambiz.
Cammies that's cute.
Sorry Dude.
That's what I call them.
Get you cammies on.
Yeah,
Btus and there were,
there we go.
I remember,
I don't know.
We are everyone I know.
We just called him cammies fatigues.
Maybe it's cute to you told God should a human being pulled guard and a fight?
No.
Oh,
unless it's a controlled like USC.
I pulled garden one,
but that's because there's one person right there and their forte is striking
and to the end of my hose,
the end of my career,
people wouldn't fall for that.
They just get the hell away from me.
But I've wanted to fights where even one the guy was across side on top and he
could have just got away from me.
But he proceeded to attack me and then I reversed triangle arm off.
It was a change leads my friend now,
a very tough guy,
but he engaged my strength.
Uh,
so you could,
same thing like cro,
cop,
probably the most notorious at high kick and history at MMA.
You know,
he broke a lot of grounds with that average guy.
You wouldn't say just left like head.
Yeah.
It's not gonna work that well,
but it works.
You do it really well.
I wouldn't say it's a good strategy in a fight,
but it's good to do because you get to a situation where you're familiar.
You have hold you up your legs and your arms engaging the opponent and you can
work from there.
But you have to have a guard.
You can't just,
oh I'm to sit in the bottom be good.
Oh,
but across my feet and I'm fine.
No,
you got beat up in a fight.
Yeah.
So if you're,
if you're good there,
you can do it.
It's not a general thing I would recommend though.
Yeah.
You know it's,
I was just remembering that when you fought Nate mark court in the UFC,
that was the,
what bummed me out about that is I can hear Jackson going,
you're not draw a punch,
you don't garden to use this like so strict that the game plan.
So Greg Jackson,
who is a really smart strategist where the smart,
and I'm Kinda like,
you know your strategists.
So it was like my strategy,
I'm supposed to be cornering you and telling you what to do strategy wise.
And Greg Jackson is on the other side telling Nate what to do strategy wise.
And after the fight I was even during the,
well that's what pissed me off was that during the fight I didn't recognize
quickly enough what was happening and what was happening was mate mark or was
just not moving.
So all he was doing was waiting for the referee stand up.
Then I can't expose nothing cause you know,
Nate was better on the feet.
He's also blocked bummed Judith be good too,
but he didn't want to play around.
There's no why take the chance.
Right.
The chance is there's a,
there's a yeah,
a much higher percentage of him getting submitted than it is of him getting
knocked out by you.
Yeah.
So he would just literally hold dean in weight and I got strategically beat by
Greg Jackson.
Now I love Greg Jackson.
I think he's an awesome guy.
And then I was hung out with her and he's a super guy and like,
it bummed me out that he tactically,
we strategically beat me,
um,
with that plan,
which was,
hey,
we're just gonna hold and we're going to wait for the referee standup.
And it was something that we didn't train for.
We didn't train for it until later.
Then we started training for like,
okay,
the other thing,
we had to start training for someone that runs away from you.
Right?
Because a lot of guys,
they would,
they would just try and get away from you.
That's all they wanted.
And so that's,
that's very difficult to contend with.
I wish that we could have a fight like in an elevator
and list your champion because I can't get away from them.
Or like in a movie theater,
like I'm sitting next to you.
Ready?
Cool.
I liked that range is,
it was my style.
You know what I'm saying?
You are meant for that.
You were meant for that.
Do you,
what do you think about when you see all the foot locks?
That's become such a huge focus of the game?
Um,
right now I'm kind of like I told you so because I,
you know,
you were in the middle of this.
I had about 10 years of,
yeah,
you're doing good with that somehow,
but we don't,
you know,
that's wrong.
Yeah.
And Oh,
by the way,
Jerry Costa Kid pay league will.
Yeah.
He actually told me when I was blue,
he goes,
you know,
Dean,
this philosophy,
it's Kinda like tacky.
And when I won,
he was there in Brazil.
When I won,
he walked,
he went in English,
she's Brazilian.
He goes,
lister fit God.
You didn't listen to me on my bullshit.
Awesome.
He's a great guy.
He is.
He's awesome.
He,
uh,
at the time it was just,
that was the way,
and yeah,
I do use some cliches,
but some cliches makes sense.
Uh,
we know the rules now you can break the rules if you don't know the rules.
So I knew the rules and you can get away with doing that because no one else was
doing that.
And sometimes they break rules because I don't want to react in a way my
opponent will predict so easily.
So I'll do something wrong because it's unexpected.
I'll do something that,
well,
those who don't do do Jujitsu and I understand this,
but I'm in new guard.
I'll reach my arm down inside.
Like I'm a white belt knowing you will go for triangle.
Yeah.
And as I I'm around your guard.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I know you're one teacher had to white belt,
they'll get caught triangle.
So I do things like that just cause it's weird.
I'm weird too,
but yeah.
So that's my style.
But yeah.
Naturebox.
Yeah.
What do you think about,
uh,
some people talk about the self defense techniques of Jujitsu and or the lack of
self defense techniques.
Virginia too.
Now what I will say is this,
I've been in some self defense classes that you're teaching and you don't focus
it on a lot,
but occasionally you'll do itself.
I act almost every time you teach one of those self defense classes.
I pick something up,
I learned something.
Okay.
Well I,
it is true.
When we were young starting,
it was from born from the UFC.
Let's see.
Motive.
It was like,
oh,
hoists Gracie.
That was the main thing.
Hixon Gracie,
you know,
valley to ODOT and back then at least your coach could fight or has been in
fights.
And I'm not criticizing anyone but it's a martial art martial being wet or
confrontation.
I'm not saying you want to be a cop,
be confrontational or be in fights,
but if you can't use Jiu Jitsu to defend yourself when it counts most.
And I don't know if it's not really a martial art anymore.
So yeah.
Um,
on the other hand,
if you think that I've had people told me this,
well you,
I DNR,
I saw your,
you're a good fight and you'll see,
oh but you know,
if you tried,
I mean I poke your eyes and I go,
okay,
thanks for letting me know.
Warning me.
Cause that's kind of scary.
I could poke their eyes too.
I don't tell him cause challenge,
argument.
See if you do one class one time,
you know,
that's why you have to roll and do it again for boxing.
You need someone to actually throwing punches at,
you.
Learn how to stop those and move away from the punches.
Just hitting a bag or,
and I hit back,
you know,
so let's see if anyone in your listening is under 25.
No one's gonna understand what that means.
But,
so having this,
putting herself in hard situations,
escape,
Jujitsu,
all is all about problem solving.
You know,
you get to a situation and you learn how to solve the problem.
You get relaxed and you learn to deal with this.
I think that's really important to know how to relax,
how to conserve your energy.
As you said,
knowing when to attack.
There's psyops,
hers,
his mental tactics.
There's a,
you know,
you could tell a lot about person,
uh,
how they fight.
You can see if they're dirty,
if they take shortcuts,
if they have a temper,
you can see if their patient,
you can see if they're explosive.
You can see if the lack,
today's go lackadaisical.
You can see it.
A lot of things about somebody if they're greedy.
That's what I'm laughing.
He's going to a accuses me of being greed and he's right.
I will get greedy with a move and I'll hang on to something that I shouldn't
hang on to.
And I'll end up in a position that I shouldn't be in and then dean will
immediately start going,
greed,
you know.
Well,
you know,
you can tell a lot about a person by how they fight and also how they handle it,
the feet and how they handle the victory.
That's why I don't do as an outward display,
but every time I win against someone,
I never run around and yelling.
I,
I check on them and if I was lose,
I shake my opponent's hand.
Uh,
I'm not,
there's nothing,
I'm not saying anything,
add more about that,
but,
but that's something I always strive to be as somewhat disrespectful.
You can see,
as you said,
humility is taught and people don't like to be humbled.
They're probably not going to last very long doing a martial art,
especially just because it's such a close and personal,
like you got owned like that and there's no escape that are belongs to Jocko.
There's no debate.
You just got tapped out.
You can't lie in a fight.
Now with some other martial arts,
it's like,
well,
you know,
if this was real fight,
I would have done this or that.
Or if I would have punched him harder,
I would have done something else.
I would have done some different,
it's like,
did you do too?
You just got,
you got put in a position where this dude could have ripped your shoulder apart
or put you to sleep and killed you.
So,
so there's,
there's truth in Jujitsu and that's why it's so humbling.
So I said,
you could tell a lot by how someone is,
uh,
okay.
If we have a sport,
like,
okay,
cough or sprinting,
these,
these are all sports and they're good.
But I don't know how someone is a swinging a golf club.
I can't tell too much about the personality,
but if someone takes a punch and they look right back at you and they punch you
back,
yeah,
that person's a,
there's something about that guy that's different than the average guy who turns
away and runs away.
Okay.
Um,
if someone tries to our mock me and I relax and I escaped,
I time it correctly.
Okay.
There's timing and his technique of course make some kind of sense.
Um,
I don't know,
back to the salt offense aspect.
Yeah.
I think,
I think you should be prepared for worst case scenario.
And actually for some weird reason now that I can fight,
I don't know,
one even messes with me.
I don't,
I don't go,
I'm not going to try to pick,
pick fights where they went,
but for some reason like no one even tries to fight me right now.
I wonder why I'm not,
but you know what I noticed like Bro,
you know,
in Japan and Russia and Brazil,
whatever coratia in any country you can imagine I'd been to for some reason and
I'm,
I'm by far like not a,
um,
a criminal or something like that.
But for some reason you get,
you get a lot of these gangster mafia type guys that are fans and you end up
hanging out with these guys and it happened in Russia.
I'm not glorifying anything but these guys,
you wouldn't even know they're gangsters.
These guys are powerful.
These are powerful guys.
You don't want to anger.
And also Jocko himself navies.
Hey Jocko,
what do you do?
I'm an investor.
Um,
Jocko,
where you're in the navy.
Yes,
I was in the Navy Jocko.
What did you do in the navy?
Well,
I,
okay,
I wasn't healed.
Whereas maybe at 19 year old kid who wants to be a seal will be like,
I'm going to be,
you know,
he's going to say it and a young fighter or someone who wants to be a fighters
can be like,
yeah,
you,
I'm a UFC fighter.
You get a really established fighter.
He's not going to usually say I'm a fighter.
I braked was arms and not,
it's not usually that way.
Also some of the richest people I know you wouldn't know the rich cause,
but I've met girls,
I dated girls who they have one nice dress.
They're poor as hell,
but it looked,
it looked like the rich were they going out there trying really hard to look
rich.
Right.
So it's interesting how,
how,
when when you understand things more,
it's like,
I don't think you have to,
it sounds corny.
Prove it.
I think you just,
you just,
you got a higher understanding about that.
The confrontational,
uh,
of human beings.
I've talked about how when you roll with someone you've never rolled with,
but where you meet someone and as soon as you make contact with them,
as soon as you clinch up with them,
you could tell something to tell him what's up and you can,
you can kind of tell like,
okay,
this is going to be,
this guy knows what he's doing this because this person doesn't really know
where they're okay.
Or wait a second,
I'm not 100% sure,
but I'm going to find out pretty quickly.
Members,
Sasha,
dude,
his aura was strong.
His Alicia was way strong.
He looked like Shrek.
Yeah,
no,
the ease,
Croatian straight east
borough if,
if you got Shrek and like took away his green skin but like a pill,
polar bear white skin on him.
It looks like a Shrek.
And he actually,
he wouldn't mind me saying this because no one really knows his full name.
He was quote hops main training partner and uh,
he,
he didn't speak English.
He speaks Spanish.
He served us some prison time in Spain for a felony,
let's say.
Okay.
And so we were talking in Spanish the whole time and he came to San Diego visit.
That's how you met him.
And that guy,
you know the first time I had trained with him at Cro cop's,
Jim hub has a gym under his house is full gym with a Cajun Sasha,
ways to 30 probably duties.
Kind of got his head on the size of this 25 at nine 10 you know,
and he has really good hands.
That guy's hardcore.
He was locked up with his head and his duty.
Come on,
he's,
he's just like,
yeah,
he's a great guy.
I don't think he and cro cop or in touch anymore.
I'm not really for some reason,
I mean core up don't talk so much anymore.
But he was the resident grappling guy slash coach training partner.
So I arrive and I'm like,
I'm kind of like the new guy.
Like hey this,
it looks at me.
And there was that little bit of like,
okay,
this is the new guy and we train and he got me in an well an arm lock behind the
head and I'm like,
I'm not tapping to this.
And I got an,
I got him and I'm like,
I should adapt to that because it was the first time,
you know,
I'm not going to,
I don't really.
Yeah.
And he was probably doing the same thing,
going to be real good friends.
He's a better wrestler than me and a better boxer than me and he has good
submissions,
but my in his head,
yeah,
you hit it.
Pardon me,
you hit his head can actually hurt your hand.
Actually he'll just take,
he won't even blink his eye.
He's really confident guy.
He's solid,
you know?
So you get some freaks like that.
Like a bowling ball of fury.
Yeah.
What should beginners focus on in Jujitsu?
Finding a good coach is imperative because you need some kind of direction and
in the end,
or hopefully sooner than later,
you start developing your own way.
Even if it's a little,
a little variation of what your coach is saying.
Uh,
maybe it doesn't have to be some champion.
Someone you connect with,
you not listening,
you can hear what they're saying because someone,
I might,
I might say something and on the dagger mom would say the same thing and the
slight variation,
it will make sense.
Maybe he says over me and vice versa.
I've had people both ways told me,
you know,
something that you will say made more sense or something that someone else said
the same exact thing,
but sending it if away.
So finding a coach is really important.
Uh,
also,
well,
humility will be taught by itself,
you know?
Um,
so that goes without saying.
I always tell people,
relax.
There we go.
Yeah,
of course.
Relax.
Of course.
But that's difficult for a beginner because you don't want to relax.
You want to win.
That's why I try and make it so evident that that's the most important thing you
should do.
You know,
a lot of people also ask me like,
what schools I live in Cleveland,
I live in Toledo.
What school should I go to?
And I think one thing that people should realize these days,
the days of like,
Hey,
there's some shyster that's running around saying he's a black belt.
There's not a lot of those guys left anymore because the data that as just
overtaken them and they just get called out.
So,
so I think if you go to a place that has a website that lists the instructors'
names,
the instructors maybe show some of their competitive history.
They show their lineage of where they got their black belt from Salt Lake.
You can't put that stuff on the Internet.
You can't say,
I got my black belt from wholesaler Gracie and not if you didn't,
and expect to have like expect to get away with that.
So do you know who Rafael Tory was?
He was a,
yeah.
So that's back to the day.
They were like,
yeah.
Um,
so you said I,
can you drive me out to the forest?
I have a to go to.
And they drove him out there and he got out with all this stuff and went the
forest and then came back like three hours later with like a trophy.
And then
Joe Rogan,
I was with a drug or Eddie Bravo and he's like,
yeah,
I beat 10 guys.
I'm paraphrasing by the way.
That guy was.
Yeah,
and he fixed fights.
It's like you fight a student.
It wasn't work.
It was a war 15 years ago.
Force.
He's in prison now.
It's gone.
So that guy,
this is an example of what it used to be like a guy could show up somewhere and
he put a black belt on and be like,
yeah,
I'm a,
I'm a black belt.
I got my black belt in Brazil.
I trained down there for four years and I'm a black belt and I won this and I
won that.
And he didn't win anything and he was just a liar.
But these days I'm telling you,
if you find a,
if you find a place online,
it lists the instructors,
the instructors names are there.
You can Google the instructors' names,
you can see if they've,
every instructor has competed at some point.
Right.
I mean if someone's,
I would say 95% of instructors have done some competition at some point.
There may be a few very small percentage of instructors that have never
competed.
Yeah.
I don't even know if that's possible.
If you've,
if you Google your instructor of your instructors never competed.
I would definitely be suspect possible.
But yeah,
it's not likely competition.
Like I said,
you could see how someone is the truth.
Yeah.
I would say one piece of advice I would give to people is,
okay,
I'm in Cleveland,
whatever,
or there's eight school.
Whenever five
go to each school.
Don't say you live there.
Say I'm visiting from yeah,
it's you're lying,
but it's wildlife.
Yeah.
It's okay.
God will forgive you.
You say,
hey listen,
I'm a,
I'm a white belt,
I'm from Florida.
I'm just passing through.
I have no experience.
So you're not getting the sales pitch.
You know,
the instructor was representative,
not his real self trying to press.
So we signed a contract.
Signing a contract is okay,
but if you believe in and the instructor you'd like we saying you like the
environment cause then as a visitor you're going to see like this,
this person not trying to sell me something.
You could see how that actually are and if you hear what they're saying is
making sense to you and you,
you vibe with the energy or let's say the style or the personality of the
instructor,
go to all five gyms in this,
pay the day fee,
2030 bucks and try it and then come back with which one did you like best and
then try it out.
And yes,
Jitsu is awesome because also you're not getting hit in the head.
Yeah.
You know,
and I love boxing.
Boxing.
Cute.
It's awesome.
I've done it at a high level of,
I've fought Wiltshire,
I sparred BOJ,
Ascii of Spark Co coppice Bart,
a gentleman,
the banner who's also one of the best in history from France.
That's why living in France for one month,
that's how I know it's a French you up,
you do get hit,
you get hurt and you only have one brain.
And it's not wrong.
It's not bad.
It's good to know everything.
A little bit of something.
But you can actually spar and Jujitsu without getting,
you can spar everyday base.
Yeah.
Unless you're injured.
So that the damage,
if you do get an unfortunate like any sport is distributed around your body,
which boxing,
it's mostly your brain.
So it's okay,
it's good to do all this stuff.
I mean I like it all.
Uh,
also grappling and assault defense scenario.
I mean even if it's more than one person,
the fact that someone cannot easily put me on the ground.
If two guys grabbed me actually like average guys,
I could actually probably just win the fight but what punch it,
but they're not going to take me down that easy.
Okay.
Someone grabs you from the side?
I can,
I could throw them,
I can get escape and I could leave.
Right.
That's something you said when it need a lot of sense.
If I decide I don't want to fight and you can't restrain me,
I could leave.
Yeah.
I don't have to.
Nowadays with all the lawsuits and stuff like that.
I mean just making a fist is ammunition for a lawyer.
That's,
that's a sign.
Okay.
Matter of fact,
he hits him with the open palm.
It's not a mini jurisdiction is not the same if you restrain someone.
If you had to,
and I,
and I call,
is it similar to that?
I say this is it a drunk uncle technique because if you had a wedding and your
uncles had too much to drink and every family has one of these uncles and
usually so they're like,
I understand what saying,
but you have to stop him.
He's doing something that's really the sea,
not,
not cool and he's hurting someone.
You could hold him without hurting him.
He can't do that with boxing.
Boxing is awesome,
but you're going to hurt someone or maybe not.
Uh,
and uh,
I know people who have hit people and fights,
the guy falls,
hits his head and dies.
I know people and they're in trouble.
And imagine your conscious,
how do you feel about that?
Does,
does so big?
It's all good to know.
San Diego does surf,
Kis are for kids.
Uh,
they knocked some kid out,
I heard about this and the guy who's not knocked him out as exactly that,
knocked him and punched him in the head and fell down,
hit his hand and curb died and,
and dude,
you don't went
to prison,
so let's,
that's whatever,
manslaughter or murder.
So whereas if he would have just done a double leg and choke the dude out,
which is more kind of more humiliating,
I think in a way
it's,
where am I?
Yeah.
I'm on the beach somewhere.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good way to do it.
Uh,
so you find a good school.
I always think the proximity is important too.
Of course,
you know,
get something close to your,
if you've picked a school that's an hour away,
you're not going to go as often.
You're going to get struck John for your time.
Yeah.
Well,
I always,
you know,
we always picked schools that were,
there were two in San Diego County.
Yeah.
There's a ton and ton in San Diego.
They're all over the place though.
There's Jujitsu just goes everywhere.
You know.
I think we've done a pretty good job of being a political at our gym of just
look,
man.
Guess what?
We loved Jujitsu.
We loved the train Jujitsu.
We love to teach Jujitsu.
We love to roll Jujitsu.
If you fall into any of those categories,
come and train,
come and get it.
And we don't,
you know,
that's just kind of our attitude.
It was a quick,
quick story.
Chocolate,
you would appreciate it.
And I'm not gonna say his name because you know,
uh,
been training here for a few years.
Nice.
Nice guy actually came to me and said,
hey dean,
um,
I want you to know,
I really like training with you.
You're my coach.
But I was,
I was invited by hundred gov own for two months.
Come train with them for free,
you know,
said okay if I,
and I'm like,
yeah man.
It,
first of all,
most men wouldn't ask them.
You have that.
You would just go and do it.
The fact you asked me,
and I've thought,
he's a friend of mine,
I'm like,
and he,
he was like,
who's ray surprise?
He thought I was gonna be mad or something.
Um,
but if he,
if he,
she went and didn't say anything,
it will be a little awkward,
which has happened to us in the past and like someone does something weird and
um,
it's a little bit,
let's say not polite or not correct,
but that was,
would that be taking ownership of the problem in his mind?
He actually told me up front or asked me and I was like,
yeah,
right on.
It was good.
And I,
I wasn't lying either.
It wasn't me being like fake jealous and I was like,
hey,
he's a friend,
he's awesome.
He's a champion.
Go.
I said,
I don't want to use with a student and her friend,
I want you to come back.
He's like,
I'm coming back for sure.
And so yeah,
we're not political at all.
Yeah.
I was found that just like it's capitalistic system in my opinion.
It's like go train where you're going to get the best training of evil
capitalists,
evil capitalism,
and like,
oh you,
you,
it's not
you train where you get the best training and now there's a level of loyalty,
right?
I mean,
you don't just bail on people that you've trained with for a long time and
there's a level of loyalty and that that's not like some level that you are
holding a gun to someone's head.
It's like,
man,
you're been trained with someone for a long time.
You keep training with them and you have a relationship with them,
you know,
and you don't just throw that out the window because you think someone else is
going to teach you a different mood for something.
It's not you.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Um,
but it is a capitalistic system.
So you go train,
where are you going to get training and,
and that's the way I,
that's the way I feel about it.
Yeah.
And I think if you're somewhat confident in your ability to save the environment
you create,
that you're a part of,
it's not so much about threat for someone to go train somewhere else.
Everyone's phone.
It's not a big deal.
That's why I'm like,
cool.
Yeah,
go.
It's fine.
Cause we know what we do here and other gyms.
It's like,
yeah,
right on.
Let's,
let's,
let's train.
Jujitsu is my overall philosophy of all this stuff.
I had a female friend,
um,
we're a pretty girl and we're about the same age.
She was one year older than me and her first real boyfriend,
I knew him too.
It wasn't real close to him.
He was very jealous and she,
I'm going to go up my car and the kid,
she would,
she's a while their girlfriends and he'd be bad and they'd make up the,
in the fights.
They broke up.
Eventually a few years later,
she actually dated a guy and he was,
he was a cop,
but he was like 28,
so she was 22,
28 year old guy hit a little more mature than the guys and straight to pull the
business with this guy.
She said,
I'm going to go up my girlfriends,
he went,
oh sure,
have a good time.
And she's okay.
She's trying to play this game with them actually.
So it wasn't,
it was equal back and forth game with proof,
proof of previous relationship.
And I know inside information that she was playing,
he was,
it was a game,
child's game.
And um,
she get ready and about to leave.
And I said,
hey,
listen,
um,
you know,
I like you to expand time with you.
But,
um,
I'm just saying,
I,
uh,
I had my own expectations and you know,
I don't really want to want to be with a girl who goes out all the time with her
girlfriends.
I mean,
have a good time,
go have a good time.
And she's like,
wait,
no,
I don't want to go out.
And she didn't go out.
So it's funny how he actually let her go out and she didn't go out the,
I said,
no,
I don't want you to out.
Shit went out of course.
And I'm not saying how to manipulate or quick,
that's,
that's some psychology there.
Would there be a dichotomy there?
A chance that a dichotomy?
I don't know.
I just felt,
I felt like saying that word one time today.
I don't know why I said No.
I said dichotomy a little too much.
But then another ego he asked me and I said,
by the way,
I wasn't playing again with him.
He wasn't playing together.
It was actually sincere.
I said right on man,
have a good time and do it.
It's a great training partner,
great Greek camp.
And I could see in his eyes he was very happy about the response.
So yeah,
I think that's uh,
taking ownership of the situation,
which is awesome.
It's good for sure.
Right on any,
I think we've been going two hours,
man.
Anything else?
Uh,
back when you were saying when used to train with Jocko
at Fabi is,
and you said he was the kind where if you guys were would roll out of bounds and
when you come back inbound,
what do you think he would want to reset or if I have let's say a x person so
and so and um,
I have the arm on the ground either Kimora halfway locked up.
We were a lot of balance and okay,
let go of it.
Average person wants to start where you don't have the keyboard golfing.
Yeah.
Chuck was like,
you had two arms on my,
on my army and I'm like,
whoa.
I know.
I'm like,
no it wasn't.
No,
I had mama the ground.
You've got two arms and all my called it cut.
Dammit.
What would to have the worst situation.
Most guys want to cheat kind of.
Yeah,
exactly.
I was the one doing the stuck of that because if you're super competitive in
training you'll pull that kind of stuff.
Like should I go now?
We'll pull not,
he won't cheat like that.
But Jack was a little more stingy.
Selfish.
I don't think I ever had that experience where you'd want to stay.
Or like if you,
if you'd be in an inferior position,
we go a bounce,
you got against the cage or something,
we'll restart.
And then you want to start like even Stevens.
I've never had that.
But the thing is people do that all the time.
All the time.
So I was wondering,
Oh maybe Jack was like
the other day and I wasn't.
I was like,
oh no,
I like,
we got close to the wall.
I don't know.
We got to close to another people that were rolling and I wasn't like a good
position.
I think I was actually a cross side and if I get across on you,
you,
you know,
you've known and so and so we,
got a little close to these other people and,
and you know,
like,
well their foot hit hit him or something.
Say we get it move and then he likes kneels down.
And I was like,
okay,
but here's the thing.
Okay.
So here's the thing.
Let's say someone does that to you.
What's the rule in your mind?
I'm sure you were actually mentally in their head.
Now are you allowed to say,
hey,
no,
I w I had no or right hand,
but it's more critical and that's the equivalent of trying to have,
trying to be like,
oh no,
you didn't have my arm all the way there.
That's cool.
That's fine.
By the way,
stuff just escalate mental notes.
You can't say,
I don't know how many of these themes I have,
like I had just finished.
Whether that's a cool for a minute sweater,
like I was just,
I don't know why it just crazy themes,
which I'll cope and it
smack talking themes.
We'll get he,
he does like,
excuse me,
when I heard there were hills,
be a Venezuelan soccer player or
I'll talk him with an accent,
but here's like,
oh man,
on geography,
like chocolate.
If you want,
I'll just get up and you can,
it's okay.
It's all right.
Just let just tell me Dean and Jack would be like,
I did it other guys before if you want me to.
Yeah,
thanks.
I'm like,
what?
I said it now.
I'm like,
I lost my mouth,
Bro.
I'm like,
actually they don't joke in the,
I'm joking.
Right.
What are the best psychological warfare you,
they don't mean it was like when you acted like you didn't want to train but you
were actually fired up because I had,
I had kinda gotten the best to you the day before.
I think it was a morning or something.
I was in the morning and you're like,
yeah,
I don't know.
And you're like,
I got to go soon.
And I was like,
in my mind I'm thinking,
okay cool.
I'll just get a quick round,
you know,
five minute round,
no big deal.
And then he was all in the game.
So Hema,
ma'am,
were you there that day?
He mounted me for like 30 to 30 minutes and was torturing me.
Well that's all the snow angel,
the whole nine yards.
Was it water torture of Chinese water torture and with the drips of sweat in my
year,
that left a mark,
that one,
one of those,
it's really jacked up though.
He's really jacked up that I'm a grown man.
I trained Jujitsu on a regular basis.
I work out,
I eat good food.
And yet you dean lister can't get a position on me that I can't get out of.
That's not cool man.
I don't like that.
You have your days too by the way.
You smack talk sometimes too.
You do the arrest them.
You did that to me sometimes,
but that's the retaliation.
It's retaliatory.
There are,
you have,
you have three positions you can get on me and crushed me.
I have to cross side and mount.
Yes.
And I have to,
I keep money.
I used to have get the back.
I got hold on you now.
I really can't hold it
but uh,
but I only have two so I can only talk smack in two positions and it's for all.
Yeah.
So interesting.
Uh,
element of you're smack talking as well.
Sometimes it,
it'll transcend the mets.
Like you can go home and get voicemails.
Oh yeah.
Oh
really?
Interesting.
I used to just spam is for them.
I send like videos or pictures.
Um,
man,
one of the funniest ones to like,
you didn't do this
earlier today.
This is just kind of unique.
I don't know why and my comment or some weird today,
I was feeling good though.
I'm like,
I'm a,
I'm going to fuck with chuck was head and I'm like,
I can take a position and I would call it 22.5
and I'd take it out and
I'm like,
no comment.
I'm like 99.3 and it's
gotta be something in your head like,
what's he doing?
I,
I completely turned to your,
your volume off and I put you on mute in my head.
But that was what accent is the most annoying for you?
Um,
man,
I dunno.
I Dunno what this way the Russians pretty good.
The Russians at the mouth and you come up to skip
or Arnold or whatever.
It's just,
yeah.
But yeah,
he gets,
gets used to it.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it doesn't impact them too much psy ops to,
well that's my Syapse is I try not to show any reaction whatsoever.
It's actually funny.
Dave Burke was watching.
Good deal.
Dave [inaudible] was watching Andy and I roll and he afterwards he was like,
you know,
it was cool to watch your role because first of all like it didn't even look
like anything I've been training.
Right.
Cause you guys were just getting crazy.
And he goes and I saw,
uh,
I saw like emotion or I saw facial emotions on you.
And I was like,
what do you mean?
He's like,
you'd normally just look like the same all the time.
And then when you're training or when I was training I'll share it with Andy,
Andy all I was like,
you know,
some taste is crap and trying to move and all that.
And uh,
so yeah,
that's one of those things.
It's one of those things,
that's why I know that whatever I'm doing is micro successful when you increase
your sense of urgency because you're all normal faith the whole time.
Even when she was my face,
normal face north.
And then occasionally you make me scramble a little bit
cause you can't,
that's the thing,
you know,
you're getting to a point where I can't just allow some little,
some little situation to occur because I can go to,
it's like the,
the,
uh,
the event horizon on a black hole.
Like,
Oh,
if I let this,
it's done.
Yeah.
If I let this go,
it's going,
it's going to go.
And the better you get,
the,
the more I got to pay attention to where that event horizon to make sure I don't
get myself in a situation where,
you know,
we've got a problem.
You want to hear an Echo Charles Story.
So I,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I expect talk to you a little bit.
Not,
not the same extreme as chocolate,
but last time we was the last time maybe,
and I'm like,
I didn't let you pass,
but I was kind of like waxy days go like,
oh he's cross.
And I went,
hey,
echo,
here's my arm.
And usually he's like,
there's something wrong.
Like it's a trap.
And usually there is a trap.
I was just talking smack and echoes like,
Oh okay,
I'll take that arm.
And I'm like,
God dammit.
He called my bullshit,
you know,
because most guys go,
there's something,
there's some reason that he's given me the arm,
you know,
and you're like,
yeah that was just going to give me an arm.
Like this is a trap.
But I knew that,
you know like,
cause you were talking smack the whole time we were rolling the whole time.
Yeah.
22 it's funny that for anyone that's listening that thinks that dean might be
this big smack talker.
The funny thing is is that you own the only,
yeah,
my friend actually a lot of times when you teach moves,
you're like,
this is a move that you would only do to someone that's very good friend of
yours or someone that you hate,
which is really kind of jacked up if you think about it.
Like,
oh he doesn't mind grinding his elbow into my temple for three or my ribs
because,
cause I'm as broke allegedly.
And so he,
but he won't do it to someone who doesn't really know that well,
because that wouldn't be,
you know,
that's not cool.
But if you,
if he hated me or if he was friends with me,
they need,
then I'm going to elbows to the ribs when he's trying to come near me.
That's awesome.
Well,
and really when you really think about it,
you're smack talking is never ever like serious.
Oh yeah.
And
it's never like the greatest new store.
It's not that it's all your Arnold impressions or your police man or you know,
all these,
all these things.
It's all like literally jokes,
but the jokes just to kind of think they're not always that funny when it's
occurring to you.
That's the genius of it though.
You see what I'm saying?
I love when the tables turn,
oh,
when the tables turn,
if you're,
if you're talking smack and I can get the tables to turn,
Oh man,
that's when I have no mercy.
It's,
it's gotta be shocking to some people were either one of us,
you and training,
you're going
to wall to wall and I'm like,
oh,
this is awesome.
The two you do it.
And like in reprisal to me are the,
the cop you did that.
But in like revenge,
like if he gets it like,
all right sir,
I'm like,
cut.
Dammit you're mine.
You're in the wrong neighborhood today.
I'm like,
God dammit.
I want to get out of this neighborhood is not cool.
And he also do the,
I'll do it too.
I'll start,
I'll light the fire.
Oh,
that's your guy here.
I'll do like bad Brazilian accent.
And when he got on top you're like,
oh,
you do it back to me.
I'm like,
God dammit.
I don't like your,
I don't want to help you with something.
Like I want to reverse to where it was
horrible.
It wasn't your tooth right on man.
Well,
like I said,
we've been going for a little over two hours.
So Dean,
anything else?
Not just a eight.
My Bros here and that would have victory in Maine.
You know,
like Jack who said,
yeah,
I mean there's been some rough times and yeah,
some,
some unique things that I'd been through.
And you know,
that's how,
you know,
you have a real pro,
a real team stick by my side and it'll help me actually,
you know,
if I can help them as well.
I know they know that,
you know,
my dad,
he actually,
you know,
did not bring him easy.
Not saying he would,
he was a real good dad,
but he,
you know,
I know it's not popular to say this nowadays,
but it may be tough.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
hey,
you got to fight.
He did you fight hard?
Did he fight hard?
Not,
Oh,
poor you.
you know,
we're going to,
we're going to make a complaint and all,
I'm not making some statements saying my dad was awesome or marine.
Right.
Didn't you say that if you weren't a seal?
We marine,
we were saying,
someone said,
I'd say there's a really good percentage that if I didn't join the seal teams,
I would've gone to the Marine Corps.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's a pretty good,
yeah,
pretty good assessment.
Yes.
My Dad was kind of like,
how you raise the war?
Like you know you're going to do this and,
and yeah,
you don't force the war,
but you kind of encourage him to do certain things.
And that's how my dad was.
That's another little torture that you do with thorough with my son.
With a,
I don't know why I go.
Um,
I don't know why.
I just go,
hey Thor,
what's her favorite food?
And he'll go like,
oh,
steak.
I'll be,
no,
I'll throw him down and I'll be like,
piggies in a blanket.
He's like,
no,
it's not.
Say No.
No.
Say it.
It'll go say,
hey,
he's on a bike.
And they'll be like,
no.
Okay.
Pig is on back.
No,
sorry.
It's torture him.
Where did you come from?
No idea.
It's just something I thought.
Of course I have no idea why it just pick a theme.
And then the fourth time he was like,
all right,
take it.
Oh my God,
you said it correctly.
So you earned the privilege of letting me like coffee right now.
That's a Siop.
All brothers got to do that.
You know?
It's just the way it is.
That's how it is,
man.
That's how it is.
One day the pecking order will be reversed,
right?
Yeah.
I know.
I was talking to me now.
Well,
I saw you.
You,
you went to take him down or whatever it was the first time you actually
definitive mocad days defending him saying,
I went to double.
They come like he actually said he's wrong.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
I had to turn up the heat.
Awesome man.
Well,
uh,
echo,
it looks like,
I think everyone's going to be training Jujitsu now.
Everyone is going to get on that path.
How can we get on that path to stay on that path,
you know?
Yeah.
I'll let you like that.
So you get to,
if you do G,
which we recommend,
we recommend
you get an origin Gig,
get Orenstein hundred percent.
No,
you didn't even have to.
Are those the ones that don't rip at all or something like that?
Oh,
I don't know that they rip.
I've never seen witnessed one rip ever.
I've never witnessed one even come close to ripping or even having the sound of
ripping sounds.
Oh by the way,
that's an investment because Jocko,
how many keys have we gone through?
Like a lot of days.
Yeah.
So I've ripped someone's Geek in a match by the ladder.
Hey,
awesome.
I think you taught me that.
Anyway,
get origin g that's the made all made in America from the thread from the cotton
all the way to the actual [inaudible] all made in America.
Assembled in America.
And also if you're going to train Nogi yeah.
Which we also recommend right?
Fully.
So you can get a a rash guard,
which is very good for training Jujitsu with cause it's compression and it
doesn't get caught up toes,
fingers,
fingers.
So you can get that.
That's true.
The rash guards and they are also made a hundred percent in an America.
Where we go is,
where are you guys?
Online origin main.com.
It's in Maine.
Um,
and yeah,
you can get sweats,
shirts,
you know,
lifestyle stuff,
apparel,
real cool stuff,
lifestyle stuff.
I said,
okay,
we'll leave that one with that.
His lifestyle bread.
Do you get to trends?
Sands,
the maps.
Once you find the way broadly,
you see it in all things.
You see what I'm saying?
I don't think I see that.
I don't think I see the way in John.
I'm just saying it's going to be your lifestyle is what I'm saying.
You see what I'm saying?
You'd knows what I'm saying.
Hunting.
Oh yeah,
there you go.
Boom.
Also supplements.
Okay.
Jocko had supplements.
Good News,
Jocko.
Supplements.
You had a surgery on your shoulders.
Same Day.
I had surgery by the way.
Actually.
Thanks for four.
He gave me,
he'll be out with some,
some gear.
Oh,
cure what?
Joint warfare patient.
Yes.
Yeah,
so that's going to help you see like mine is waived.
Remember Kay,
I did my other side to my buy side.
This one's healing way faster.
Ignite and day.
Wait,
crazy faster.
Anyway,
joint warfare,
so supplements Jocko has thankfully joint warfare.
Glucosomine can Jordan,
you know grappling,
we always kind of knew about that.
The crow,
curcumin and then also Jocko.
Super Krill oil,
which is good for your joints.
The joints,
lubrication,
Omega threes.
What not other good benefits for that too.
And you can get disciplined.
Yeah.
Not just regular discipline,
but a supplement called discipline,
which is good for the pre mission situation.
Dave Burke.
Good deal.
Deal deal.
Dave,
he's on the discipline.
Yeah,
a lot.
So here's the thing about discipline going to sick k.
So I'm like,
all right,
that's not an every day deal for me.
Discipline.
Oh.
So I'm like,
oh no,
I'll take it.
You know.
Cool.
I'm down.
Um,
so I'm like,
all right,
so let me do the three.
Oh,
you didn't hear,
I heard some good things about the three scoops.
So I did the three scoops and,
and here's the thing,
I wasn't like tired or nothing like that.
It wasn't like,
oh,
I need this specific label.
Let me just do the three scoops.
Good for your program.
A little bit of this,
got to do it.
So I get in three schools,
boom.
I go and here's one thing that like,
I wasn't necessarily trying to pay attention to him.
I remember everything and my sharp,
I wasn't trying to really paying attention to that.
I was just going to take it and be like,
okay,
what happens?
This is what I noticed what stuck out to me.
My patients like you don't want to increase in increase in life.
So like you,
you might think that your patients would go down because you're all here but you
don't get that.
But it's not,
it's,
I mean it's slightly caffeinated and like her dose of caffeine but it's not,
no,
like maybe maybe caffeine might make you like that.
Maybe,
but um,
cause it's not that I don't,
I don't know what the mechanism is that made me patient,
but I really,
you know how like through the day you'll get,
you know,
it'll get tested.
Things won't go your way or whatever.
I felt like,
Oh man,
it's all good.
Like man,
I'm problem solving.
And in there that's giving you emotional discipline.
Yeah.
Like it's like,
it's like making my mind like PR solve problems rather than like be all,
you know,
you have little micro reaction.
The inside internally.
I mean I'm not a bad behavior.
You're cute.
What
it felt like I could manage that like really good.
It was like really easy to manage that.
That's what it felt like.
The on the three schools that,
that's my three scoops.
That's what happened.
Boom.
Either way,
discipline,
Moke
biking or something like,
it's actually a word that I literally created to make something and I was like,
hey man,
this has to taste really good and it has to have a great profile nutritionally.
And when we,
when I finally got the sample where I wanted and Pete and Brian McCall,
he got so good and they sent me my idols like oh it's so good.
And I'm thinking,
well it's not even a protein drink.
It's something else.
It's milk,
but it is so it's just a word,
but it happens to have 22 grams of protein in one's curse group and taste like,
like a for rest probiotics or something too.
It has probiotics
and peanut butter.
Chocolate is now also available.
It's a big hit in my household.
Brought mine too man.
It's fun.
That's all I had to eat today by the way.
I had,
I had milk,
a triple milkshake milk.
Put some heavy cream in there too.
Not a lot.
It's a little bit.
And then um,
oh,
I know I had a worrier bar too,
but that's all I had to pry him on a mock train.
Big told.
It's like,
it's like a protein supplement and a dessert.
So if you're like,
Hey,
I'm lifting,
I'm rolling.
Um,
working out hard,
you eat dinner,
you can have a dessert.
Boom.
That's a protein supplement,
right?
The
not,
okay.
The Mint is delicious,
but let's face it,
I've been drinking nothing but men milk for whatever.
How ever long it's been released for.
So now all of a sudden I've got a little option.
Yeah,
the new and it's new.
It is new,
but it's awesome
when you open,
here's what I'll tell you what,
when you open up either one of those two and you smell them,
you know,
you know you're,
you know things are about to get real good,
real good.
Either one of them.
Can you vanilla and next time we're working vanilla.
I have some vanilla.
You like vanilla for real.
No kidding.
Yeah,
I made the vanilla and give him to my son.
He's too,
by the way.
I think he thought it was like a for real milk,
like a dessert.
And he was like,
oh,
he's all like crying for it.
Have a video.
I sent it to Pete for real.
It's funny by the way.
And that was vanilla.
It's not just going to be vanilla though.
Gotta be vanilla something vanilla gorilla
is for real.
He was like,
are you serious?
And I was like,
yeah,
I mean,
of course.
And he goes,
he goes,
what do you mean?
I said,
put a white gorilla on there.
The Vanilla Gorilla is combat.
I would expect so much from John.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
So we took a picture of you dean inputs,
but you on here,
boom.
Make sense?
Uh,
immersion camp by the way,
that Dean will be at,
and I would say come,
but if you didn't already sign up,
you're not going to be there because a,
it's sold out.
No kidding.
Official,
official sold out.
We'll be doing it next year.
We'll try and get,
you know,
come next year.
We'll try and expand it a little bit,
but it's sold out.
Sorry,
next time.
But those are fun.
I talk a little about that with people very often because they want to go
anyway.
Was good.
Also good way to support and support yourself and represent boom,
three things.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Jock was a store called Jocko store.
You go to the Jocko store.com right,
makes sense.
Anyway,
this is where you can get the shirts.
The hoodies is more rash guards,
more Jocko representative.
You know,
kind of a little bit more direct message on that one,
but some good stuff.
If you want to represent a,
yeah,
go there.
Jocko.
store.com hats.
Yeah,
that's good.
Whatever.
Flex fit hats.
Flex fit the Nouveau snapback chic.
That's what flex flex fit our new Gucci
hoodies.
Legit hoodies and lightweight hoodies.
Yeah,
the lightweight hoodies.
Here's the thing,
right?
You made me like stutter step on the lightweight hoodies,
so like I have them in,
but they're not like in the pipe yet,
but we're good.
Keep them out of the pipe.
Now they're going in the pipe or there's people that there's,
there is people,
there are people,
a lot of support for the lightweight.
Everyone in Hawaii,
sir,
a bunch of people in Florida.
Sure.
Texas sometimes too.
But yeah,
that's a good way to support and represent.
Like I said,
[inaudible] dot com also good way to support is to subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already.
Seems obvious.
I know,
but on iTunes and Stitcher,
drill obvious in school,
go play this for 137 episodes and I think I even say it seems obvious.
Every single diaries I have you say it seems obvious,
which kind of in Moraga which makes,
yeah,
exactly right.
But my point even more,
it seems obvious because I say it all the time and that's just kinda how with
podcasts you subscribed to the podcast,
that's how everyone knows that when you say things a certain way and then,
then you just think that's the best way to say it and you're just going to keep
saying yes,
it ain't broke,
don't fix it kind of thing.
Even though it kind of is broke because you look at me like his broke every
single time.
Either way.
When you're signing up for podcasts,
don't forget that there's also the war,
your kid podcast and you can subscribe to that one too.
You can play it for kids.
There's some stories on there.
There's some Q and a for uncle Jake,
which you know it's good.
Yeah,
I liked the story.
So k those stories I have to,
should I shorten it sometimes,
but all those stories I tell my daughter before bedtime stories.
Now you have a story now you know how like do you make yourself the first person
or character or do you save this aunt and Uncle Jake?
I actually don't even say uncle Jake.
So how do you make us different names?
Different names.
She thinks she's buying that.
Yes.
She's like,
you ripped this off from Jacqueline.
Dad,
come on.
Where are you at?
No,
no,
no.
She knows and he was think they're interesting.
We're running a race.
Okay.
No,
I don't say me.
I don't see me.
I say,
look,
there was this girl who owe me money.
Yeah,
kinds of fun.
Like a royalties like scenario.
But you say someone else was running the race.
You say a story about some buddy and he was the important thing and hasn't she
heard the warrior kid podcast?
No.
Oh,
you know,
you've evil no holding out on her and you're taking my stories and now you're
making it your own.
And one day she's going to listen to me like she stole this story from daddy was
bad is I didn't realize those doing that.
But technically that is what happened.
What happened,
what happened?
It's cold blooded.
But either way,
if they don't hear those stories on the podcast for whatever reason or whatever
or what have you,
you have stories to tell and you know they're going to come with that lesson.
That's what I think is yet another element of value.
Immense value.
Keep podcasts through some of those stories on the,
uh,
on the youtube channel.
Yes.
The JOCKO podcast,
youtube channel,
and there's a warrior king podcast or a youtube channel.
So go to youtube,
subscribe to that if you want to see echoes,
legit videos,
which apparently he has some in the hopper and he's going to be releasing.
So we're looking forward to that as well,
which shouldn't be good.
Get them out there.
I think so.
Also on it.
Okay.
On att.com/jocko this is where you can get your kettle bells.
I got some heat for calling them artistic Kettlebell.
Actually,
it wasn't called them that for seven years.
It wasn't here.
It was like an intro oriented.
What's an artist like?
Primal bells.
The ones that look like faces on them on they're the gorilla.
He was where they were for,
but don't even think brother the best
you do kill us.
I used to.
Yeah,
so you get the werewolf warm is way better anyway.
Even looks better anyway.
They're cool and,
and you get it from on it.
So there's that.
I got rings and there's a bunch of other work.
Cool workup.
Sticking with couples are awesome.
Yeah,
but if they look awesome,
that's even more awesome when you saw the regular ones too,
by the way.
But that's what a lot of information to ama website,
psychological war.
It was psychological warfare and we're working on the second album,
but that's on iTunes.
If you want to hear me talking about
when to get after it instead of being a little baby and succumbing to your own
pathetic,
horrible laziness and we thought was nice.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah,
there's that.
Yeah there's white tea yet.
Jocko white tea in cans too by the way if you like tea and a can or if you just
like the whole idea of holding a,
you know like can you do with the energy drinks or whatever.
Jp told me today he's at caught.
Can you just pay me and Jocko white tea cause you know reason to have salon
front and I'm like brother we can make it happen man.
It's ordering Jocko white tea which is awesome.
Like I said,
it's awesome because as I said last time AP he used to get on those energy
drinks,
make time for that.
Now he's just getting on a little Jocko white tea.
Dean's been hammering the Jocko white tea and you're also an energy drink guy.
Yeah those,
those were the days where it wasn't regulated,
you know.
Oh Yeah Phaedra tea drink.
Hey do you drink tea?
Like in normal,
like everyday life.
Are you a drinker?
Yeah.
That's weird.
Right.
Me Too.
But I piled niece upon these older houses so I stopped,
I stopped using like the red bull type stuff.
That's not really.
Yeah.
And when this is like a transition kind of thing.
Make sense?
You had uh,
an of like an energy type drink the other day and because I was driving and I
needed a little bit of energy and it was like one of those ones that had said,
you know,
like all the,
all the little buzz words on it,
healthy,
natural,
blah,
blah.
So I drink this thing and all of a sudden,
30 minutes later I feel like I'm going to start stabbing like the road with a
battleaxe and attacking people.
Like it had 200 milligrams of caffeine to 400 milligrams of caffeine.
Yeah.
That's going to get you,
what are you doing?
Give me all that.
Are you psycho?
You're right.
It's their fault.
No.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
It's all their fault.
Not your fault.
Good.
How's this?
So my wife,
she knows she's on the path of my life,
big time actually now,
just like boom on the path.
So listen to that podcast that I looked at her phone and it has the podcast.
Oh,
it's not that she's just on her own.
And I'm like,
oh man.
So I'm like,
okay.
The other day,
okay,
this is just an,
this was me,
this maybe to start maybe three,
four weeks ago,
right in the game.
So the other day I hear,
I'm like in the site,
not in the next room,
but kind of like to the side.
I'm not in her visual like so her,
you know,
people don't,
I'm not saying my wife talks to herself,
I'm not saying that,
but you know,
you say something,
you say,
oops,
you made a mistake,
just got under your breath,
can stuff.
She's like,
no.
She goes,
she pops another one of these can't just like,
I love this stuff to herself,
not to me.
She was like on her own,
like popping them and yeah,
she's,
she,
she's founding this,
this stuff.
So it's interesting.
I asked.
Here's the thing,
she is kind of a tea drinker.
She likes like if you,
okay.
If it was a blind double blind test and you just,
you just came into a room and you'd never drank this before and you picked up a
cup,
somebody put it in your hand and put it in your mouth.
Would you say it was tea?
I would,
but I'm not like a,
hey,
that's,
that's tea.
You know,
I'm not a teaching or,
that's why I asked.
I was asking if you're a tea drinker because I know it tastes like tea if you
drink tea,
but if it was just,
if you would just like you in a,
in a store and grabbed a,
can you open,
you'd be like,
oh,
this is interesting.
You wouldn't maybe necessarily,
no,
it was tea maybe.
Yeah.
Well don't say that in England.
That's evil over there.
I think it's,
yeah.
Oh,
it's bad tank.
Okay,
well they just don't drink it.
They drink their tea warm or hot and with milk in it.
Do you put milk in that?
I know,
right?
It seems like like a psycho thing to do with this one.
Don't do that nonetheless.
Good.
Hey,
I got some books where the warrior kid books for your kid.
There's one of them.
It's called way of the warrior kid.
Then the second one in that series is Mark's mission.
Got The discipline equals freedom field manual.
If you need to know how to get after it,
that's where you find out how to get after it.
The audio version,
that book,
you get it on Itunes as an MP,
three or Amazon music or Google play or whatever.
Also got extreme ownership.
That's about combat leadership written by by me and my brother Leif Babin and on
September 25th the dichotomy of leadership comes out that iconomy of leadership.
It's a followup.
Leif and I wrote it.
Fall of two extreme ownership dives in and it gets granular on how to balance
the opposing forces of leadership so that you and your team can win dichotomy.
You liked the word
things all smiling and I was waiting for you to say it actually.
I said it once.
I only said it once.
This podcast,
which is weird because I should have said it a bunch because in Jujitsu you've
got to be aggressive,
but there's a dichotomy because you can't be do aggressive,
you've got to be offensive.
But at the same time,
you've got to also,
there's a dichotomy because you gotta be defensive,
right?
You've got to train with the Geeky.
But there's a dichotomy because you've also got a train without tags me and
yeah,
so there's a dichotomy there.
He ended Ogi both of important.
So you've got to do it.
A leadership consultant company Echelon Front,
we solve problems through leadership.
Whatever problem you have at your company,
your team,
it's a leadership problem.
Um,
I'm telling you that right now,
it's a leadership problem on some level.
It's a leadership problem.
If you want help with that,
you got me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
and now Mike Cirelli as well.
And that's what we do.
We'd come work with your company and get those leadership problem solved,
which will solve whatever inherent problems are within your team,
your company,
your business.
Muster zero zero six in San Francisco,
California,
October 17th and 18th all the other ones have sold out.
This one is apparently on track to sell out even faster than all the other ones.
So if you want to come to that,
go to extreme ownership.com get registered,
we'll see you up there.
Leadership Seminar,
two days of
granular practical leadership.
It's not,
it's not a motivation that they can get.
You can do this,
and I'm not saying you won't be motivated because I get motivated,
but what?
We're not there going like,
how can we motivate these people?
That's not even,
that word's not even said at any point at all.
Neither is you can do it.
Yeah.
Do you ever say that?
Never know,
but how the strength today,
he was a strong person.
You believe in yourself,
you are great.
For sure.
That does not what his ass,
that is not what is happening.
We talk about leadership and leadership is the most important thing on the
battlefield.
It's the most important thing in your business and it's the most important thing
in your life.
So if you want to come and learn some pragmatic leadership skills,
then come with the muster.
Also for current law enforcement,
military border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics,
first responders,
all you out there in uniform,
we got roll call number zero zero one is our first roll call.
We're having roll call because the musters two days,
it's pricey and we wanted to offer something to military law enforcement to the
folks out there in uniform to come and get a condensed version focused on the
dynamic leadership situations that you all face.
That's September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
You also register for that@extremeownership.com and also we now have f Overwatch
echelon front,
Overwatch,
overwatch.com okay,
so this is it.
We've been working with companies for all these years.
All these years we've been working with all these various different companies
and all these companies.
We work with them and help their leadership.
Well,
they want to hire leaders,
they want to bring leaders on board.
We were also in the military,
all of us additional on front were in the military.
And we have connections with a lot of people that were in the military that,
that want to go work at jobs with great companies.
So in order to connect those two groups,
people that want jobs and people that need leaders in their business go to
[inaudible] dot com to get in the game.
And you can either register as someone that's looking for a job to focused on
special ops folks and combat aviation,
those types of what we're looking at right now,
we're going to broaden that out and put together another company in the very
near for another arm of this company.
And,
but that's where we're starting because that's basically the reason we're
starting.
There's cause that's the element that we have connections with.
And so as we expand,
and we're working this right now to get the lines of communication open in the
other branches of the military so that we can bring on board,
you know,
uh,
other folks.
But again,
this is,
we started with the groups that we know.
So if you're in those groups,
go register.
If you're getting ready to retire,
if you're looking at getting out and you don't know what you're going to do
next.
We need leaders,
America needs leaders.
These businesses need experienced leaders that understand the principles.
We talk about the principles that are in extreme ownership of the things that
you learned in combat.
The things you learned leading troops on the battlefield.
You're skills are needed.
So hit us up F overwatch.com.
Get registered,
get in the game and we'll get you,
uh,
get your next mission.
Talk About having your next mission all the time.
We will get your next mission.
You've got a bunch of companies that are,
they need you.
And if you want to spend some time with us virtually until we're Roland,
til we're rolling up a monster or Brolin in Texas or rolling it at the immersion
camp.
Until then,
we're all up on the interwebs.
Dean,
Dean lister,
Dean is at on Instagram,
Dina's at Dean Lister Bjj.
That's right on Twitter.
You might not even remember this on Twitter.
Your Dean underscore lister.
I looked up to see if you had Twitter,
you had a post,
your,
your last post was in 2010 did Twitter exist in 2010 I'm not even kidding.
I thought Twitter was like three years old.
No.
Has it been around that long?
When was it invented?
Easily before 2010 it makes sense.
I knew that well cause he just kind of said he did.
Amen.
All good.
Yeah.
When three years ago factually,
uh,
and uh,
Facebook,
you do you do Facebook?
Yeah.
Instagram.
Yeah,
it's again more now.
Basically there's one,
it's like a fan,
you know,
they make the audit generate one for you.
If you find you go see you or whatever,
if you have a certain amount of friends.
I personal one it's me and my mom,
my sister in the cage.
And then there was another one.
I don't know.
What is mean.
Remember you made,
no,
you didn't make me,
but you asked me to set you up one like eat 10 years ago.
Yeah.
But there's another one.
Oh,
another one on top of that.
It's actually post things about me.
But what's the real one?
It's uh,
just dean lister.
Yeah.
It's just,
that's me in a cage with my,
my mom,
my sister.
Yeah.
Right on.
Uh,
and that's where you can find a snow.
Of course.
Echo is at echocharles in all mediums.
Yes,
I am at Jocko Willink.
Echo.
You got anything else?
Nope.
Pretty cool to hang with dean in this capacity.
You know,
like I see every,
literally every time I come here pretty much literally pretty much.
I see.
You know,
whatever,
by the way,
you're my first actually your class,
it was my third.
She did some class really old to live with that in that half
a strong back then too.
If you ever heard him tell that.
So like he thought he could take you kinda.
Yeah.
I told him a couple of days.
Okay.
So the mean cake not story is different.
So it was like when I,
for the first time I ever rolled with you,
you were like,
Hey,
I've come roll like you.
Yeah.
And I was like,
how,
this is literally what I thought.
How embarrassing is it going to be and how awkward is it going to be if like I
get dean today?
Like that's how what I was thinking that I was literally not to sit and he
wasn't like this fantasy.
It was literally worried about the awkwardness.
So that's how really it was to me.
I didn't,
I'm not saying I was going to get you,
but to me there was a chance,
but I was like,
yeah,
it's okay.
You know,
he'll,
he'll respect that.
If that happens.
I'm not saying it,
we'll put it in my kind of thing.
Right.
When you,
you know how you were saying right when you locked up,
and this is uh,
yeah,
this was maybe like a week or yeah.
Oh five.
Yeah.
So this may be like a week or two into Jujitsu.
Right.
Even then,
right when we locked up,
I knew that there is zero chance of me beating Dean right now.
Maybe Dave Burke came on and we were talking about top gun and how like he,
he set it up really nicely and he's like,
oh,
he,
if he had a guy that was really good about when this whole thing,
he's like,
then his chance of beating a,
you know,
me as a top gun instructor would be zero,
0%.
There's no,
and that's kind of the situation.
Yes.
There's literally,
I'm saying there's actually no possible way,
no possible way that you could have submitted dean lister,
no possible way.
And I knew that like literally right when we locked up and I was like,
okay.
And it was,
um,
uh,
and even at that point,
even before this was like when you were in pride,
this was like right after you won or maybe right before.
No,
no,
it was right before you one.
ADCC oh man.
Or right after,
I don't know.
I remember one day you came in and everyone cheered for you cause it's the first
fish.
She started my shadow on the super fight.
Maybe.
Yes,
that's what it was actually.
Yep.
Know,
Jacques Machado and the super fights that we had come Prieto who's an awesome
guy,
came up to help train you.
And so we were all training you and we were all training with you and,
and uh,
when we got to the fight,
this is the,
this is the difference in attitudes,
right?
So he got to the match,
I won't call it a fight because it's not a fight,
it's a match.
And you are going against John Jacques Machado who is a legendary,
legendary Jujitsu player.
And when you got to like a dominant position and you were up by life,
hold on.
Hey,
you're up by like three or four points.
Like go for the
hold right there.
Hold,
you got this,
you know,
like that type of thing.
Strategical and Brazilians stick by there and on the goal.
And
it was funny right before the match coach trained for like three weeks,
you know,
and a over right before now she goes,
Hey,
do you didn't want to talk to you?
He said in English actually,
he went,
just so you know,
I came down here to help you and if you don't win today,
I have let you down.
And I feel like I'm a,
I'm a like whatever.
I was like,
he's like,
so if you lose,
I lose her also.
And you know,
I really hope you win.
And I'm like damn to the oppression,
you know,
cause that ownership,
I don't want to let you down if I'm not,
I don't want to,
you don't let some cy ops on.
You're pretty cool.
And it worked.
But yeah,
that was uh,
yeah,
that was it.
Those good.
It's good.
Well it's cause my point is cool to hang with you in this capacity,
you know,
slightly different,
but it's more simple than nonetheless.
Dean,
any closing thoughts?
I'll just,
uh,
you mentioned the first responders.
I think for them.
Most importantly,
get on the mat.
If you any kind of forced smarter and you deal with erratic people,
I think it's really good.
Uh,
it does take some,
some measure to put yourself in the situation where are,
you will be
weaker than people to get stronger.
But I think it's very important.
I think that's,
I see more seals than I'm at that I do cops.
I think cops need more and then a seal.
I know.
So I hope to see more of this from first responders on the mat learning this
kind of stuff.
It's just really valuable.
Definitely.
I look forward to the immersion camp at the Ford.
Awesome man.
Well,
uh,
obviously thanks for coming on Dean [inaudible] or we've been putting this off
for a while and I'm sure he'll be back on again and we'll talk more.
Jewishy it's stories.
Got a cow and thanks to everyone else out there for listening and,
and especially those of you that wear the uniform.
So,
yeah.
You know,
military police,
firefighters,
border patrol,
paramedics,
all their first responders.
We know that all of you make sacrifices every day to protect us and we
absolutely thank you for that.
And like Dean,
I also hope that all you and all those jobs,
find some time to train some Jujitsu because it'll make you better at your job.
It will make you better at life.
And if you can't find Jujitsu,
go find some boxing or some judo or some wrestling or some Moy Tai or some way
to train so that you can fight when the time comes.
Okay.
And,
and really that goes to everyone that is listening to this.
If you can get out there and fight
you out there,
fight,
literally.
Okay.
And fight metaphorically in your everyday life.
Fight against the enemy.
Fight against the criminals.
Fight Against Fire and catastrophe.
Fight against your training partners.
Fight against your weakness.
Fight against slaw off,
fight against laziness and stagnation and fight to stay on the path and live in
accordance with the way.
Yeah.
By getting out there.
Okay.
And getting after it.
Until next time,
this is dean,
an echo and Jocko
out.